good morning everybody uh welcome to the
education committee uh today we have uh
a number of bills on the docket here uh
let me go through and try and explain
some of the things that we're
encouraging those that testify to do if
you hear have heard something that you
want to say at that's already been said
or submitted to us in writing um that
that a person has right here and like
representative Cordell is sitting there
testifying right now please don't
replicate that or duplicate it say just
I support that so that we you don't have
to hear the same thing over and over and
save some time for the questioning and
which is then digs down drills down a
little bit more in into the topic from
the committee to the people speaking
that will certainly help the way the the
meetings are held the person who is
sponsoring the bill the prime sponsor is
given latitude as far as time then I
look at the number of pink cards which
we're receiving here and we have on a
number of bills had to put a time limit
and time limit depending upon it's
either three minutes or two minutes
based upon the number of cards I receive
one of the issues which occurs is that
we look and see oh there's only five
cards here so we can open that up or or
maybe 10 cards here we can do that with
three minutes but all of a sudden during
the bill a lot lot occurs and we have a
pile in of another 10 cards then we have
to eliminate down to two two minutes so
please support us on that we're trying
to get everybody up to testify and we
welcome your presence today the first
bill which we have is HP
1419 this is relative relative to
prohibiting obscene and or harmful
sexual materials in schools and I'd like
to welcome the prime responsibil
representa Glenn cordelli uh thank you
Mr chairman uh thank you fellow
committee members um and um thank you Mr
chairman for starting out the day with
an easy Bill uh for the record uh state
representative Glenn cordelli
representing tufton buror wolfboro and
oop in the beautiful Lakes Region uh
house buillt 419 1419
um is a reworked bill from uh last year
the bill last year was tabled I have
worked uh spent considerable time
working with the attorney general and
attorney bond from his office um on on
this um legislation and what I'd like to
do is Step you through it um if I might
and provide some of the legal
underpinnings um as we go through
it so on uh the first page page uh
section one um this is from the criminal
statutes right now there are certain um
institutions exempt from our obscenity
laws my change here restricts that
exemption just to higher education K12
education will no longer be exempt from
our obscenity
laws uh um and important thing to note
here is in talking with the attorney
general he thought it would be rare and
would have to be an extreme case for
there to be any criminal prosecution of
anyone um related to this
legislation the next thing uh is section
two uh starting on lines basically uh
which is a new section of
Law and it relates to the important
topic of materials that are harmful to
Miners and that's key phrase harmful to
miners U we'll be talking about that
um the point is that that is what we are
interested in materials that are harmful
to miners you know you might hear um or
have seen things on social media or
outside about banning books and so forth
that is not the purpose of this
legislation this is the purpose of this
legislation is to prohibit materials
that are harmful to minors in our
schools so starting on line uh eight on
down you'll see a number of
definitions um including nudity uh
sastic abuse sexual conduct
Etc
um the next section I want to point out
on page two starting on line seven is
the material is harmful to miners
when
this items one two and three are taken
from state law and federal law it dates
back to the
1960s where there was a case uh Ginsburg
versus New
York and um Sam Ginsburg and his wife
owned a little lunchonette and they also
sold some magazines including what was
called girly
magazines um so uh he ended up
selling um two of these magazines to a
16-year-old and was um uh caught doing
that and prosecuted under New York penal
law section
434 which prohibited the selling of um
girly magazines and materials harmful to
miners um under the age of
17 uh he was found guilty in State Court
state supreme court and it went to the
US Supreme Court and that's Ginsburg
versus New York is the uh case
um the Court ruled he was in violation
of the
law um the Justice again Justice Brennan
uh
said that well let me step back once
this is where the concept of variable
obscenity comes into play variable
obscenity meaning that something that
might not be
obscene for an adult could be considered
obscene for a minor the term they use is
variable obscenity so Justice Brandon
reasoned that the New York State Statute
and I quote simply adjust the definition
of of obscenity to social realities and
serves the state interests in protecting
minors so that's the um Ginsburg versus
New York case
and uh this has
been these um um purposes that you see
one through three are in federal statute
now um 20 USC
F7 um this is taken from there um it's
also in various States I've read that
Most states have language in their laws
related to materials that are harmful to
Miners And this is uh the most common um
thread in that regard um item number
four um is my addition in that it's
inappropriate to miners to whom the
information is being made
available the next section I wanted to
point out is uh a complaint section has
been uh added complaint process and
these are minimum requirements for local
complaint
processes um complaints can be made by
parents or Guardians about materials
that are available in the schools to
their children uh the complaints should
go up the line from the principal you'll
see on line
27 going on up through uh the principal
uh if there's um they want to appeal the
principal's decision they can go to the
school board that's on page three uh
section Roman
6 um they can appeal to the school board
and then in section seven an agreed
parent can appeal to the State Board of
Education um if need
be so that's the
minimum complaint process that must be
in place in local
districts the next section C is the
enforcement and penalty section
beginning on line uh 27 on page three
and this is in the Civil section of our
statutes so it's possible that a civil
action could be taken um against the
school district under two circumstances
and that's on lines 31 and
32 when the school or school district
and has not
uh adhered to this complaint process or
the material complained about continues
to be made available to
miners after a
determination pursuant to the above that
it should not be available so those are
the two uh criteria for a complaint a
civil
complaint um the petitioner if
successful can be
awarded not less than $1,000 for each
violation and then there is a provision
also that uh violations can be uh
considered um a violation of the
educator code of
conduct so
that very simply hopefully is the
legislation and the legal pinnings for
this legislation so it's been tested at
the United States Supreme Court um and
in state courts around the nation um
Georgia Etc i' I've looked at a number
of states um legislation in this regard
um I'm not going to get into um some of
the materials that uh might be found in
our schools I think maybe there will be
others um who will uh talk about that uh
I just wanted to to talk about uh
specifically what the intent of my bill
is and the um requirements um that I've
included uh in the legislation with that
thank you very much thank you very much
representative cordellia are there
questions from the committee for the
representative not seeing any thank you
very oh yes representa whitcock thank
you uh ear just a question on the uh
complaint process um I'm looking at uh
21 through 30ish on page three two GL U
where did that come
from the the complaint process um it's a
comp
comp yes right thank you me m um I need
some more coffee I guess um from several
States process that I looked at um as
well as my additions um based on um uh
processes here in New Hampshire
follow yes thank you so this process is
not in place anywhere this is just your
compulation of stuff right yes thank you
that's not a direct pull from any
location okay thank you thank you chair
yeah Ron cordello thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question and for
bringing this uh Bill forward so my
question relates to on page two where
you have uh it's Roman numeral 2 for
purposes of the subdivision materials
har to minors when and you give uh Four
Points there and the first three are as
you indicated the they're commonly known
as the Miller test so it's been a is
that you're taking that um just for my
actually kind of a two-part question so
um is this language taken directly from
sort of that Supreme Court
precedent um it's it's taken from
several courses I don't think it's um
directly related to uh it partially
related uh I guess to the um Miller
versus California case you mentioned um
a lot of it does come from there but um
I I looked at that as well as
specifically the Ginsburg case because
that was directly related to
miners okay and then a follow up because
of um part four so the first three are
pretty much a
standard three-prong test that's been
used for decades to standardize
definition of obscenity I just was
wondering if you could clarify a little
bit the fourth point the material isn't
inappropriate to the age of miners just
a little Clarity of what you mean it
seems a little vague so what you could
you elaborate a little on that last
point right I I think um I wanted to get
to the heart of it in
that the material should be age
appropriate so that was the reason for
my addition there line for um you know
what might be uh appropriate to a in a a
high school uh classroom or made
available to high school students uh
very possibly might not be appropriate
to uh an elementary school
library further questions from the
committee he has represent
bbon thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um when we looked
at the similar Bill about this last year
it was brought up that many districts
already have policies to address
complaints um how is your process
different I assume that you've looked at
a lot of those policies and um why do
you feel those policies aren't
sufficient
um I wanted to lay out what I thought
was a moment a minimum requirement
including the appeal to the State Board
which um I don't know um how many um
local processes
have rep representative Tanner
thank you um under uh on line 13 on page
one the higher education shall mean any
institution in the University system uh
and that's the only one that you exempt
Exempted from the um education Statute
in the criminal statute of obscenity so
any other educational institution any
other educational
organization
um other than the higher other than the
university system uh is subject to this
bill uh I I think that that definition
was taken from existing
statute so should it be
changed
I it's it's committee's committee's Bill
now is that your intent what did that
only the university
system and the community college system
right yes that's your intent
yes representative
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you so it
seems to me that we already have this in
law um RSA
571b is a harmful to minor statute it's
not clear to me why we need this
bill I I believe that we need something
uh specifically related to um materials
that are harmful to miners with
everything we've seen going on around
the state and around the nation um we
need to uh tie this
into um sexualization of children uh I
think it's important to uh provide um
the definitions and the requirements um
in terms of what are harmful uh to
minors um according to uh the US Supreme
Court and many state laws as well so I
think that um that is the
need follow up thank
you I appreciate your concerns and I
still think this is duplicative have you
read RSA 571b was that considered in the
drafting of your proposed legislation I
I considered more um um you know what
has been handed down by
by the US Supreme Court and other courts
um in uh drafting this and in working
with the attorney
general one more we have a lot of people
that want to ask questions go ahead it's
just not clear to me why we would want
to create a redundant law so maybe we
need to consider that more thank
you further questions yes representative
cascaden thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative for taking my
question
you uh mentioned that
um the purpose of your bill was because
there were a lot of um specifics going
on around the state could you clarify
for me what is it you're talking about
that's going on around the state that is
not already covered by Statute um I I
think that um we've uh read about many
instances of uh um uh materials being in
uh School libraries and in tools um that
uh are objectionable to parents because
of the nature of the
materials so I think that's why this
bill is
necessary representa Tanner so before
you stated that this wasn't a ban book
uh problem uh and now you're talking
about that it's it's in school libraries
and of course libraries have their own
um regulations and and methods of
reviewing books and and that sort of
thing so um I just wanted to follow up
is it a band book is it a band Book uh
bill or not it is
not uh very simply it's not um School
libraries I'm not sure about what
regulations you're talking about that
school libraries have but I think school
libraries should uh comply with the law
when it comes to making materials
available to
minors further questions represent co
question
short I just want to go back to um only
after your response on line uh 15 of
page two when you're talking about
inappropriate um the age of the minus
how is that
determined how is the appropriateness
and age determined it doesn't tell you
there right um who makes that decision I
I I think that's part of the process um
throughout the complaint process um you
know there is we talked about that with
the Attorney General's office and um
felt that this was uh sufficient um uh
there is you know one state um that I
know of I believe it's Oklahoma that has
um um layered um in terms of uh General
Provisions more specific POS Pro
Provisions as to um age requirements uh
sort of like a um movie uh rating system
um but that is the only one that I know
of um that uh goes beyond um something
like
this yes so there is
no rating system here so it says the the
material is that that's it's the one
part that you inserted you said it was
yours but it doesn't tell you anything
about how you determine what is age
appropriate to
minor um that's all I did there's no
there's no way to determine that
I think I I think that uh age
appropriateness um is to be determined
um by the uh school and the State Board
um and the courts if if need
be thank you thank you sh I do have a
question so I'd like to follow up where
I'm putting my uh trustee hat on for the
University system now and asking why do
we have higher education in this bill at
all when we're talking about
professional employees of a school
district we're saying at the end of the
bill that you're we're referencing the
code of ethics which is not applicable
to uh the noncertified professionals
from professors at the University in
Community College I understand Community
College may have dual concurrent rment
and may be dealing minors but would you
recommend that we strike out higher
education from this
bill
um I left right now it just says
education is exempt from the exended
laws so I left it I wanted to remove K12
from that so I left higher education in
there um I did not want to get into the
discussion about uh you know medical
school possibly uh providing something
that someone might consider um
uh obscene or uh legal um a law school
um who would be examining cases and
looking at testimony and looking at
materials from prior cases that might um
raise questions about whether um there
was obscene material involved in the um
law review of
materials so I you know
if if someone thinks um you know higher
ed should not be exempt either um you
know we we certainly can have that
discussion thank you further question
representa Tanner thank you um I'm I'm
wondering on page I'm looking at page
two the um the enforcement and penalties
and um I'm we I can't remember an
education bill that we've passed that
has a set fee of like $1,000 minimum and
who collects those fees and do they go
and also um isn't that an incentive for
false accusations to come
through I I don't believe it is because
there are um uh criteria laid out um on
lines 32 and 33 as to um what would be
subject uh to a civil
complaint
quickly so are we prescribing to to the
courts or are we giving the Department
of Education the ability to assess a
fine of not less than $1,000 it's the
courts this a civil section this is the
court we're telling the courts what they
have to
do I I think u in our legal statutes
you'll see uh uh Provisions made out to
uh amounts of fines um jail terms Etc so
I don't see that this is any different
than what is done in law uh throughout
the country isn't that criminal law
though not in all cases
no okay let's I'd like to move on we
have 15 cards here represent B Bon do
have one last aching question go
ahead thank and thank you for taking my
question um I just have it's not really
spelled out in here but obviously in
health education um there's descriptions
of sexual education and some of these
terms that you use in here um pictures
and descriptions can be used to describe
sexual intercourse and um contact and
questions come up during those
discussions
um they couldn't be
misinterpreted um and I I think with the
our statutes related to uh sexual
education parents can uh also uh opt
their children out of some of those
lessons
okay are there any further
questions I I know but we will have a
chance to do that during exec session as
well okay go ahead represent whitcock
thank
you on the def representative Cardel on
the definitions on page one yes um those
came from some other place those came
from um the uh New York penal law that
was upheld by okay so I'm looking at se
ual conduct and I read through it
quickly and I should have read through
it more clearly would this impact some
of our our cheering squads some of our
dance squads some of those programs some
of those teachers that teach
choreography that teaches different
theater and plays I'm I'm I'm I'm
visioning some of the acts that you're
talking about here and thinking back on
even looking at last week's uh drum line
uh at the school so would that would
that fall into this category Shing
theater I've never seen cheerleading at
any football game that I've attended or
basketball game that would uh fall under
this sexual conduct you've never seen
that gyration or anything uh you you you
must be going to a Baptist school okay I
think we're ready going on some other
questions here thank you uh we're we're
going to move on now from the prime
sponsor to folks that have driven down
here for that just got a note from
Michael Strand and your card was next on
the list anyway so um so I'd like to
invite m
Strand and the limited time is going to
be 2 minutes due to the 17 cards I have
here Cole that's
all thank you representative vad for
giving me an opportunity to speak before
I have to run back to work um and I will
do my best to keep it uh as close to two
as possible um my name is Michael Strand
I'm a Bedford resident and town
counselor um speaking for myself only
today
um and most importantly I am the dad of
a 10-year-old girl in uh Bedford public
schools I'm here to testify against this
fill because I have serious concerns
about the real intent and the Practical
inability to enforce it should it become
law in addition I believe it would cause
serious long-term delerious consequences
both intended and unintended on our
school system and most importantly our
kids ability to learn and think for
themselves free of government overreach
and
control
quick story uh in 1938 my
great-grandmother uh left Slovakia in
the Far Eastern edge of Europe next to
Ukraine she was eight months pregnant
she got out before Hitler invaded um she
was by herself she didn't speak a word
of English and her first job was
sweeping the stairs of the Empire State
Building uh my paternal grandfather was
in Pearl Harbor and once spent two days
in the open water before he was
rescued our grandparents didn't fight
against f reg
regimes so that our children could go to
school in a country that makes it easier
to ban
books however well intended this bill
may be however we might all agree there
are some things we may not want our kids
to see at certain ages it's up to us as
parents to know what our kids are
reading not to impose our personal
family or religious values on a whole
class or school or District or in this
case a whole state and let's be honest
this bill is not about protecting my
10-year-old from pornography in her
fourth grade elementary school library
because there's nothing even remotely
objectionable in that Library I've been
there even if there were there are
already suitable mechanisms for
librarians parents teachers principles
to curate the curriculum in age
appropriate ways based on the needs of
their local districts and populations I
know this because they already do
it this bill in my opinion I believe is
about censoring and curating High School
curriculum to fit a political agenda
kids are far past the Age of Reason
should have open access to information
in order to learn how to think
critically they should be exposed to
information outside of their comfort
zone they should be challenged they
should question because real learning is
controversial freedom is controversial
there's no other
way to the committee I would ask you
when will we stop wasting time and
taxpayer dollars on culture wars which I
believe this is connected to and I know
I have to wrap up here um there's some
language in here that I wanted to focus
on quickly and
uh you can kick me out um I have
concerns that may perhaps there might be
some questions for you and you can
integrate that into your responses can I
just make one comment about the
escalation piece of it uh uh biggest
concern is that this undermines local
control uh for locally elected school
board members and districts um the uh
Clause that mentions app parent Guardian
May appeal the local Schoolboard
decision to the State Board of Education
is problematic and that's the most
important thing I wanted to share today
um you know I don't think we should be
willing to relinquish any risk of you
know losing local control um it should
be up to Local District uh local
principles and you know not designed to
intentionally create an environment of
fear and censorship where parents or
politicians with minority viewpoints
might be able um to escalate this if
they're motivated by special interests
and override local Authority by you know
appealing to the school board and part
of the reason for that um is I believe
that our school board itself uh or the
the board of education at the state
level um is compromised politicized and
biased um thank you if that's in your
written testimony could you submit that
that will be placed in the record I'm
going to have to cut you off right now
and and totally totally inter will you
accept questions yeah of course
representa thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question two you at
one point referred to book Banning and I
know that term will come up a lot today
you also mentioned your ancestors and
some which brings up sort of historical
precedent historically book
Banning is when a book is prohibited
like no one can get it sure it's not
published it's not available anywhere
children adults that's historically what
book Banning is sure so considering that
this bill is just calling for uh
prohibiting a vulnerable age group from
seeing material that can objectively be
judged as harmful to them uh how exactly
is this a book ban because I think it
creates a mechanism where you can
escalate this to uh you know the uh the
Board of Education you know and and
again back to you know my prior Point um
you know no intent to politicize here
but right now we have a board of
education where um the V uh you know the
Vice chair of the Republican Party sits
on the board of education that's a
conflict of interest um we have a very
nice intelligent man from my own town
who sits on the board of education but
he also runs a conservative talk radio
show and has had to recuse himself from
votes before because he actually was
connected to or invested in a company
receiving a you know a public contract
from the state uh that's a conflict of
interests and you know even the chairman
of the board of education is a man who
uh no knock to him or his choices but he
homeschooled all five of his children
for personal religious reasons so he now
gets a potentially tiebreaking vote on
what material is age appropriate
acceptable objectionable or offensive
for my daughter I mean I I don't think
so that doesn't work further questions
from the
committee yes representative leus and
then representa
Damon you had mentioned that you thought
determining what that it was up to the
parents to determine what a child sees
or doesn't see and I'm wondering how the
parents can do that when their child is
sent off to school for many hours during
the day how does the parent know
everything that is in that school
library or that classroom yeah I think
it requires a level of public trust in
Educators in Librarians that actually
have to get a you can't even do with a
bachelor's degree it requires a master's
of Library science in many cases there
are mechanisms for book selection um you
know I did this in college uh is a a
quick side example and it was one of the
more challenging experience I had and I
know we're not talking about college um
I I interned at this you know sort of
radical small alternative press magazine
um and this is you know pre me too
movement pre you know some of uh the
vocalization of you know a need for um
LBGTQ representation equal rights and I
had to objectively choose books um
that were challenging for me you know
and didn't necessarily align with my
experiences or um you know or ideas that
I had never even had or values that I
potentially had but that was uh that was
a good challenge for me as a young
person to understand that just because I
may not agree with a certain perspective
or lifestyle or have a personal
experience that you know those voices
still deserve to be heard and I think
that this bill whether intentionally or
not you know with respect to
representative cordelli I think it uh
you know really threatens to undermine
um you know the sort of open society and
and you know open critical thinking and
and learning that uh is the Bedrock of
our democracy so I I don't don't mean to
be dramatic but I think the long-term
consequences of this could be severe in
uh you know unamerican frankly in my
opinion represent representative Damon
then represent
beler thank you Mr chair thank you for
being here and bringing in your personal
family history to the reasons why you
oppose this bill could you give us a
little more of you referenced that you
had some specific concerns about the
language in the bill could you speak
more to that um
sure briefly out of respect to the other
folks here um so you know uh you I just
had a couple pull quotes here from the
language uh quote material lack serious
literary scientific Medical Art artistic
or political value for miners um who
decides serious what objective system of
measurement could be used to determine
the seriousness of value when talking
about literature or politics um I was an
English major um you know I think uh you
know maybe not in high school but I
guess I don't know if I'm allowed to ask
questions I had a question potentially
for representative cordelli um you know
I'm curious if uh if representative
cordelli thinks that you can't you can't
I I'm sorry that so um you know Alan
Ginsburg I heard a Ginsburg reference
here um Alan ginsburg's famous famous
poem how uh went through many trials and
tribulations in terms of banning
um it's a it's a meaningful important
poem that's part of American history
that uh does intentionally use vulgarity
uh rhetorically uh to you know to elicit
a response from the reader and it's
dealing with mental health issues and
issues of systemic homophobia at that
time uh when gay people were openly
oppressed um this is important from a
civil rights perspective and an artistic
perspective and that that's just one
more extreme example but I think we
could find many more by Walt
Whitman what are we what are we not
going to teach thank you thank you
represent
belshire thank you Mr chair and thank
you for your testimony um you've you've
just testified that um what you've
deemed to be true learning can only
occur when children are made to be
uncomfortable can you provide any
specific examples of how children in
your District are purposely made to be
uncomfortable and how that's a positive
thing for their learning sure it's a
fair question um again this is where I
think we have to trust uh Educators and
professionals and I don't you I don't
know that it's fair to say we're
intentionally making kids uncomfortable
um and this is also again where we get
back to what's age appropriate and that
should be determined locally um you know
I'll give you a perfect example um you
know in in our town and I'm not on the
school board I'm not really that
involved my again my you know my kiddo
is in elementary school so I don't know
what you know filling the library of the
high school and you know I paid a little
more attention lately because um there's
been you know supposed controversy over
it um and you know we had a gentleman
who was protesting at a municipal
election with uh you know a pull quote
from a book um that you know made that
book look like it was you know
gratuitous vulgarity um you know the
board had actually I think the local
school board had already adjudicated on
this with input from parents in the
local community and you know the context
was
completely um you know manipulated uh
for the sake of that and and only the
vulgar content was put on a billboard
where children who probably shouldn't
have been reading that had to see it
because it was from the high school you
know so I don't know that it's about
intentionally making anybody
uncomfortable but I think that in open
dialogue especially in you know uh in
study of the arts and history and
government and uh in literature um you
know
healthy challenging conversations and
dialogue and dialectical learning is
going to happen um I don't know that
we're forcing it or
should thank you if I may just in a
brief followup does that then mean that
you would retract your specific
statement that the true learning can
only occur when enforced outside of
their comfort zone I think it depends on
the context I mean that's a broad brush
but uh you know I think again depending
upon age and content um it's healthy to
be exposed to things that are different
than what we're used to and I think it
may be especially relevant in New
Hampshire further
questions represent have you asked one
of I did that's I'd like to move on
please uh representative ner thank you
very much for your time I appreciate it
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee I'm representative ner and
I'm here because I wanted to be on
record supporting this bill because when
we know that something is inherently
wrong and we do nothing to try to stop
it then we too are at fault and I
believe wholeheartedly that letting
Little Children See perverse material
is it's just just disgusting and it it's
it's wrong and we should not allow it
thank you and that's it thank you thank
you questions thank you very much
representative uh I'd like to call
forward Mark
abar State Rep yeah thank you Mr
chairman welcome back
I'd like to speak this favor
b
o did you hear the yes yes we did what
we are here today to discuss is a step
along a path it is a step that is at the
same time regrettable as regrettable as
it is
necessary the responsibility of parents
is to determine how best to create
future
adults what we are doing this morning is
we are discussing a way to protect the
Next
Generation here are the questions before
you today why are we placing in schools
materials that are considered harassment
if they were in the
workplace why are we not providing the
same protection to children in our
schools that we provide employees in our
workplaces does that make
sense I think not enough is enough House
Bill
1419 takes a stand it is regrettable
that it is
necessary but it is time to deal with a
situation that is undercutting our
principles and our values if we wish to
continue the American uh dream if we
intend to this to have this country uh
move forward into the future with the
prosperity that we have been able to
develop in the past we need to protect
our future
generation the do nothing alternative is
just simply irresponsible we've reached
a place where we have in our schools an
open uh rep repository for material that
is uh ethically
morally questionable and we need to do
something to put up some guide
rails quibbling about how we do
it may be
appropriate but we need to take some
kind of action if this committee
couldn't do it last
year what's to what reassurance do you
provide the the public that you'll deal
with it in the F in the future in the
present you have a bill before you if
you don't like what's in
it say what's wrong with it Mark it up
and move
forward that's all I have to say Mr
chairman thank you very much are there
any questions from the committee thank
you very much like to call represent
Louise
andreis
represent is it is it y it's 1419 okay
are you wanting to speak Representative
no oh you don't want to speak that's
okay we had a card here for you oh I
thought I just put
that well that's why we have the blue
sheets there for that too so thank you
very
much uh representative David
Paige
thank you Mr chairman and good morning
everyone good morning um I'm here today
to oppose the bill I would however like
to
begin um by expressing support for part
of what the sponsor is trying to do
because I do agree with the sponsor
about one thing which is that parents
and Guardians deserve a clear and
transparent process for raising obje
ction this is already the case in the
vast majority of districts who have
policies in place but I agree with the
sponsor that something needs to be done
about that and I think we can do
something about that and I've been
trying to work on that issue on a
bipartisan basis this
year the bill before us today though I
have a lot of issues with um and I want
to touch on Four Points here that that
are problematic for me the first is the
vagueness in the way that we're defining
materials harmful to miners the second
is the impact
on
students the third is the procedure
itself which I think is impracticable
for many schools in districts and the
appeal process which a prior speaker
touched on so I'll try to stay very
brief on that
point so to the point of the vagueness
of our definitions here I think I'd like
everyone to just do a quick silent
thought
exercise which is to
imagine what material for you personally
you think crosses the line into being
harmful for minors imagining something
that just crosses over the line for a
seven-year-old now imagine what does
that material look like for a
12-year-old now imagine what does that
material look like for a
17-year-old and I can guarantee you a
couple things if we all do that one is
that we would all agree that there are
certain materials that would be wildly
inappropriate they're not there right
we don't have pornography being
distributed in school we all would agree
that's
inappropriate something else I think we
could I can guarantee is that each of us
would have put that line somewhere a
little bit different depending on what
age group we're talking about depending
on who we are what our individual Family
Values
are and the reason I I ask everyone to
think through it this way is Imagine The
Impossible position we are putting an ed
educator in and trying to draw that line
based on our widely differing
interpretations of exactly where it
falls we are putting them in an
impossible
position I'd also note that our trained
professionals who are making these
selection decisions are doing this very
thing themselves already right they are
trying to determine what is appropriate
for the children that they serve in
their particular community
so I think this vagueness is problematic
both for the Educators on the ground I
think it also guarantees as we've seen
in other states this is going to be a
long drawn out litigation process if it
were to pass this is what we're seeing
happen in other places like Arkansas
your your time is time is up we gave you
three minutes oh okay all right I'm I'm
sorry I guess I would I would then just
um I'll I'll submit some written
testimony after the fact and I would
just um stress the point that we are
going to be putting Educators in a
position where they are trying to
operate within a Safe Harbor and not
taking risks and the students who are
going to be disserved by that are some
of our most vulnerable students
including lgbtq kids including children
who have faced um sexual trauma and
violence and that a lot of the materials
that are being targeted are materials
that can help them as they navigate
those things in their lives thank you
very much are you willing to take any
questions sure any questions from the
committee representative Tanner thank
you for your testimony could you explain
a little bit um since you're actually uh
making a clear policy on how to work
through this um you said procedure was
one of your issues could you explain a
little bit more on that certainly yes I
think um I appreciate the sponsor's
intent of trying to of guarantee a swift
resolution I think that goal is laudable
but I think on the ground it will be
very difficult to implement um in many
districts you you assemble a committee
that might include a parent it might
include your school librarian a relevant
subject area teacher maybe even a
student to review the material and you
have to review the work as a whole right
the Miller test says you know the work
considered as a whole has no literary
value its primary purpose is to appeal
to aan interest right so you need to
analyze the work as a whole that whole
committee would need to read through the
material right so I think it's not
practical the deadlines that have been
set and districts will need more
flexibility I'd also note that we're
having uh in New Hampshire we're seeing
more and more of people coming forward
with multiple complaints at once so a
parent might come in with a list of 20
books and it's just not workable to
provide the thoughtful analysis of each
of those 20 titles that is needed on the
timelines provided I applaud the goal of
trying to
be you know trying to be responsive to
the complaint in a timely fashion but I
think the specific stringent uh and
inflexible uh timelines that are here
are just not
workable thank you very much further
represent Woodcock thank you chairman L
paig welcome good to see you thank you
um you you sound as you're presenting as
you have a background in this you have a
background in in uh books or Banning or
or evaluation I I work with I work with
Librarians a lot
yes thank further
questions yes representative Hall thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question one of your categories was
appeal process you concerns can you just
speak a little bit about that sure so
the way I see this is on the one hand
we're we're saying that we're making
this determination based on prevailing
Community standards right that's how
we're determining what's harmful to
miners is prevailing Community standards
on the other hand we're saying when a
local school board Mak makes that
determination a school board that's
accountable to their local community and
the people who elected them who can be
removed if people don't like the way
they're they're voting on these
things we're taking that that power away
and giving it to unelected bureaucrats
to say we disagree with your local
decision about what your prevailing
Community standards are I see that as
extremely problematic I also see it as
problematic that this would be
determined not in a court of law I mean
typically when we're talking about obs
we're talking about IL legal
determination I I find it I find that
piece of this bill particularly
problematic thank you fur the questions
from the committee thank you very much
representative thank you um I have a
card here just take on the order they
come uh bar Christina from the school
boards do you want to speak now or do
you have you don't take a position I I
you have any
technical pardon
me we'll do that you can
be hit the home run
uh Amry
bfield my jacket on so
cold
um good morning andry bfield um I'm here
to support HB 419 and I'll also be
submitting testimony from a parent a
single parent of an autistic child
living in Seabrook New Hampshire I met
Tabitha several months ago because of
the numerous problems her son was
experiencing in public school one of the
first things I do is try to figure out
how to keep a student in their local
public school Tabitha said her son once
loved his school but she could see that
he was beginning to hate it I attended a
virtual IEP meeting with another parent
advocate New Hampshire to make sure that
the school Personnel working with
Tabitha's son were following some of the
procedures that apply to autistic
children there were some problems that
were occurring with some of the school
personnel which she believed caused her
son to act out in an inappropriate way a
once happy autistic child started to
change his behavior after starting
school in the fall Tabitha explained how
her son in sixth grade told her that he
was shown sexual images and exposed to
sexual
language she began looking into what was
available to him on the Chromebook and
found the Sora app the library app the
school supply students contains
pornographic books that are not
appropriate for sixth grade children
ES
autistic child can be a bit of a
challenge but Tabitha was able to figure
out that something was seriously wrong
she even filed a report with the
commissioner and the local police as a
single parent of an autistic child she
made sure that anything that was able he
was able to access at home did not
include this kind of obscenity autistic
parents know that this kind of x-rated
material could cause behavior problems
that they do not want to have to deal
with and yet here he was using sexual I
and highly inappropriate language in
school towards his teachers then this
resulted in punishments towards him
Tabitha feels that the district making
these books available to her child
helped create behavior problems how do
you trust adults working with special
needs students who make obscene
materials available to
children she felt her rights were
violated Under Disability civil rights
and idea this all caused his behaviors
to worsen she felt it gave them the
ability to punish him
she felt she had no other choice but to
homeschool her son to keep him safe and
provide a better education for him how
many other children have acted out based
on highly sexualized content and
pictures that have been made available
to them a child who acts out but lacks
the ability to control their behavior
like other children he was not only
punished but had to leave his public
school if you care about supporting
public education children with special
needs and other children
then you don't provide these kinds of
materials obscene and pornographic as
I've reported to this Committee in the
past parents need to understand that
books that simp that they simply do not
like cannot be removed from the school
library it's too subjective however when
a book or any materials cross over to
obscenities it is considered child
sexual abuse here three minutes is up
one more statement stopit now.org is
committed to stopping sexual abuse of
children on their website it says
showing pornographic pictures to a child
is considered sexual abuse um I do have
the
parents can you submit that do is it
okay to read it publicly well I'd rather
not have something read right there for
B we can we can read that um are there
any questions for the
presenter I thank thank you very much
thank
you like to call Megan tutle this is
from
the name
and
you okay thank
you good morning good morning thank you
uh for the record my name is Megan
Tuttle president na New Hampshire
representing about 17,000 educ across
the state now we'll keep this short here
today to express our opposition to House
Bill 1419 which really just amounts to
another attempt at eliminating unnamed
books from our public schools by using
vague standards accompanied by a process
that's difficult to piece together
potentially very harmful to an educator
that's caught in the middle of
this as it was brought up before it's
unclear to us why we need this bill
since we have an objectionable material
statute that already lays out a process
for exempting a student from material
that a parent objects to their student
viewing so what sorts of books and
materials does this for hose Bill
language capture that the current
statute is not it does provide specific
definitions at the beginning but then it
becomes vague contains very subjective
standards for example under the
definition harmful to minors what does
the phrase patently offensive to
prevailing standards in the adult
community with respect to what is
suitable for minors mean the entire
sentence is difficult to assess
especially from the stand point of the
educator um that has to adjudicate the
law so who decides who decides what the
prevailing standard is which Adult
Community is the bill referring to
anyone reading the news on a daily basis
can probably surmise that we lack any
kind of cohesive Adult Community who
could arrive at an agreement as to what
is offensive is this the adult community
who thinks books about gay relationships
are offensive or the adult community who
does not this is hardly an objective
standard by which to
operate in today's climate we cannot
seem to agree as an adult community what
material holds serious literary or
scientific value with such a subjetive
subjective excuse me set of standards as
is laid out in the subdivision under
paragraph 2 this will be a difficult
Bill to interpret or
enforce this lastly leads me to our
concerns regarding the complaint process
that's laid out in the
bill the legislation calls for each
local school board to adopt a complaint
resolution uh policy but it's quite
prescriptive and ends with the State
Board making the final determination on
what is harmful it lays the first
decision on the school principal or
their designate as to whether the
material meets the vague and subjective
standards outlined earlier in the bill
and whether it should be removed or
restricted that determination could mean
that one parent's assessment of a
particular book leads to no other
student being able to assess that work
access that work excuse me the appeal
process of a particular uh leads to the
local school board and then to the state
board at the point a determination is
appealed to the State Board are they
determining whether the local school
board
followed the process correctly or are
they making a decision on a case-by
casee basis as to whether certain works
are allowable under the statute for
conceivably all students to the state so
we're left wondering what the bill
accomplishes be beyond the current
objectionable materials law other than
to let one subjective interpretation of
its vague standards affect access access
to school material that allows other
students of freedom to learn and so for
these reasons we're respectfully asking
the house education committee to find
house on the money House Bill 1419 and
expedience 18 years in the
classroom thank you very much I do have
a written testimony that has some more
to hand down are there any questions yes
represent
leus when it comes to the objectionable
material and thanks for taking my
question by the way when it comes to
objectional material which you talked
about schools have to post and publish
that my question is how will parents
know what books are in their Library
since in lots of schools they can't go
in and peruse the school library so how
are you suggesting that parents know
that thank for the question there's lots
of ways that parents can be involved in
their child's education they can contact
the school librarian if they hear that
something's in there that they don't
like if they see it on an app that their
child might have I know there's apps out
there for libraries you know for schools
across the state if they see something
they can contact the
school I think it's easy to get in touch
with the school I have three children of
my own I'm in contact with the school
they're they're teachers they're
Administration all the
time thank you thank
you yes um wouldn't that be after the
child has already seen the material how
does the parent know beforehand so that
the child doesn't see the
material thank you for the question I I
still think there's other ways that they
can do it if they're hearing things in
the community before their child I mean
this this isn't a I don't see this as a
silent issue where parents don't have
any idea what's going on in their in
their children's schools I think
something that is considered or might be
considered objectionable is probably
being talked about whether a child has
checked out the book or not or seen it
on an app and I think there's lots of
ways you can be in contact with the
schools the schools are open for parents
to contact them with questions concerns
lots of things like that thank you
welome thank you representative dry
thank you and thank you for taking my
question um I wanted to talk about um
the appeal to the State Board of
Education um it talks about the appeal
of the local School Board decision so
that would be the decision between the
parent and the school board which is um
the that's the purview of the State
Board to hear appeals and issue
decisions about disputes between
individuals and school systems so I
think that there wouldn't you agree that
maybe this is talking about that
particular ruling and the decision of
that particular parent thank you for the
question I think it could yes okay thank
you thank you re represent Damon or was
it represent Hall yeah okay thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question do you know if most or how many
school libraries have their Library C
it's online you can just go in and see
what books they have uh thank you for
the question I do not know the exact
number that have that um I could I would
assume and again this is just an
assumption without looking at all of
them that with technology that we have
today that's a pretty fair assumption
that you would be able to see the
materials that are in there but again I
can't say that for every single school
right okay thank you thank you very much
represent Tanner thank you just to
clarify the earlier question about the
uh appeal to the state school board is
the state school board making a decision
on that the local school board did not
follow the proper procedure and give the
parent the ability to go through that
procedure or are they deciding whether
the material itself is objectionable or
not thank you for the question that was
my
question
thank you very much thank you further
questions yes represent Damon thank you
Mr chair following up on representative
lakes's um question or remark are you
aware of schools where parents are not
permitted to go in the
library thank you for the question um
I'm not I know that I can go into my
school's libraries thank you thank you
further questions thank you very much
like to invite Nancy uh bman
bman
good morning Nancy Beerman um I'm here
to uh speak in support of this bill um
as a parent who has actually um brought
um questions and concerns about a book
that was brought into the
curriculum uh for our school district
about 5 years ago
and uh was um not really heard by her
school board and brought up fact after
fact that the school board did not
follow policy it was not brought in
front of the curriculum committee um the
two administrators who actually uh
proposed the book uh only read the first
two chapters never read the entire book
which I find uh horrific as an educator
um and um no my child did not read this
book and um and the school district and
the board still did not take the book
out of uh the school and the curriculum
and have it reviewed and uh looked at
like it was supposed to according to its
policies so all of you that say there
are policies in place yeah there's
policies but they choose not to follow
them so that is a big problem
um I've been an educator for 15 years
I've taught K to8 uh grade levels there
has never been an instance where I felt
like I needed to have a book that
contained graphic uh descriptions or
materials in the classroom at all um I
don't know where this push is that we
need to have this material in the
classroom um I would never choose to
have it um when students would have
questions um I knew where the line was
and today's Educators don't seem to know
where the line is anymore um I knew that
if a child asked a question and I felt
like that was definitely a parents
opinion and Viewpoint I would say you
know that's a question for your mom and
dad and that's not a question that I'm
going to answer in the classroom today
and then I would we would move on to
another topic I don't understand why
teachers feel like they have to answer
every question a child asks and then
again if that question I would
definitely call the parents and tell
them you know hey your child had this
question today in school I think you
need to have a discussion about this I
knew my place and I knew that I should
not step over that that line and
interfere with a child and a parents
beliefs and um opinions and ideas and
kids never knew what my opinion belief
and ideas were and I taught us
government for many years so they did
not know it um as far as um the teachers
uh Union saying that objectional
material that parents would know about
it before and we don't there have been
many incidences where teachers have
shown stuff and parents find out after
the fact so the kids have already been
exposed to this material and the damage
has already been done and this is what
we need to stop I don't know why this
even has to be a bill because I would
think that teachers would know and
Educators would know that this does not
need to be there and Librarians should
know that this should not be in the
schools your your time is up thank you
you're welcome are there questions from
the
committee see thank you very
much I'd like to call Dr Sydney luged
good morning good morning thank you for
your time today um I am here on behalf
of the New Hampshire school
administrators Association Equity
committee to oppose HB
1419 um I'd like to say that I am Dr
Sydney leot um I am here on on behalf of
the equity committee but I'd also like
to say that I am a 25-year U Public
School educator I have been a teacher a
principal I have been a director of
curriculum instruction and assessment
and for the last seven years I've been a
superintendent I also will add that I
have three wonderful children who have
gone through New Hampshire
schools hb1 1419 raises very significant
concerns particularly in the context of
Education the primary reasons for my
objection are the dangerous slippery
slope of curriculum bands um and I also
am concerned because there seems to be a
conflation between curriculum and
library and I hope that the committee
considers that those are not the same
thing um there are potentially negative
side effects on students in need and
once again the inclusion of conduct
violations and threats of firing
teachers is not going to help New
Hampshire students or New Hampshire
Educators I find this bill to be
redundant uh because we already have
systems laws regulations and policies in
place as many people have already stated
here that uh deal with objectionable
materials teachers and curriculum
experts are trained to select materials
that follow curriculum standards and
meet the developmental needs of their
Learners there is absolutely no need to
start uh add new language in any law
that promotes outright banss on
curriculum or books because we already
have processes in place to take care of
these
issues this kind of a law is a
significant overstep in enforcing and
imposing specific values on Educators
families kids and Schools teachers
already restrict and allow curriculum
materials through a process then they
are trained experts to do just
that it is clear that this is another
attempt on Banning anything in schools
potentially related to sexuality and
gender identity a Target against the
lgbtq community
and I really want to remind this
committee that those are protected
classes under the
law um this is also language that comes
from other states this bill is largely
language that comes from other states
this is not a New Hampshire problem I
can tell you that in about the 25 years
I've been an educator I can think of
possibly two examples where we went
through an objectionable materials
process the process was handled well and
I would argue that the Educators and the
parents both walked away feeling good
about the dialogue and the conversation
that happened throughout the
process this will add another chilling
factor that makes Educators feel unsure
uneasy and concerned about their
jobs it is difficult to hire teachers
are ready more leaving the profession
and the ones who are currently in
schools feel that their jobs and their
licenses are more on the line than ever
can you can you wrap it up you've just
gone by three minutes
absolutely um I just want to get to the
the special the effect on students and
then I'll I'll absolutely stop and take
questions um students do need to have
access to information and that is a law
and I really worry about how this bill
would affect our school counselors our
School nurses or anybody else um who
might be working with a student in need
who could be potentially having issues
sexual abuse they need a trusted adult
to help them this really puts into play
a lot of um barriers for students
getting the help that they need I urge
you to reconsider the implications of
hb1 1419 largely it is redundant thank
you thank you and I'll be happy to take
questions you have written comment could
you please submit that so we can get
that into the record represent Cordell
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question thank you it's a
question I asked before because you also
have brought up the term Book Banning uh
I don't know if you use the exact phrase
but THS were in there curriculum Banning
Banning of books and it seems that this
term has the definition seems to be
changing because historically it meant
the book would not be available to
anyone it would be prohibited and the
only way to obtain it would be through
some sort of Black Market
underground um so given
this idea of book Banning as it's
traditionally been known um how do you
see this as a ban where it's just being
uh Pro prohibit to one vulnerable group
who may clearly be harmed by the
material mostly because uh and this is
where I think there's a completion
between curriculum laws regulation
policies and libraries because in
libraries which I think is what you're
talking about right um is that students
still have an access still have a right
to access information so this is an
infringement on First Amendment rights
for students and when you are
prohibiting something specifically
prohibiting a book it is book Banning
whether it's in a school or whether it's
for the larger public it's the same
thing thank you further questions from
the committee
not seeing thank you very much thank
you uh Michael
besset morning everybody um there's been
a lot said already and I'm not going to
repeat what other people have said I
want to tell you two very brief stories
so that you can connect my name is
Michael bassette I'm the assistant
superintendent of the karge Regional
School District but I'm a former
educator in the classroom I spent uh
about eight years teaching biology at uh
sixth seventh and eth grade levels okay
and I taught in New York I'm also the
New York State first class teacher of
the year okay so that was my first year
teaching um I want to tell you a brief
story about that experience in my first
year because interestingly enough it has
application to this um I was teaching
biology I was teaching a course to
seventh grade students it was relevant
to the topic of the value of human life
and I was actually teaching a multi-part
unit in which I was comparing the value
of human Life by having children explore
the concept through cognitive dissonance
that people have and that's that that
conversation I think that represented
vure was describing about having to
learn in in a situation in which that
that jux toos between two realities
exists um I was teaching seventh graders
that different people have different
values of human life and that was a
shock to them and this is in
1993 okay where I was having this
conversation and I put it out on the
table for them that uh Insurance Company
for example value by uh you know their
Actuarial costs and all the associated
things that are assigned to that if you
melt down a human body sounds pretty
gross but I'm a biology teacher you take
all those elements down you take down
you take the mineral content that actual
H value has a value assigned to it and
so that explored process of looking at
different types of perspectives and
viewpoints allowed me to have a a moment
with children to be able to explain to
them that different purposes and
different subjective viewpoints do
matter they make a difference on all of
the ways that we experience the world
around them that's
1993 okay it's a strange situation when
I actually agree with representative
cordelli at no offense sir but the
honest answer is I actually agree with
the concept of keeping Kids Safe in
schools as a school principal for 16
years in grades fourth through sixth
grade I worked with students in an age
group that's particularly vulnerable in
that regard and I can tell you firsthand
that I had experiences with parents many
experiences with parents one primary
story sticks out in my mind in which I
had to literally take out and send out
Communications to the school and a very
wealthy affluent Community it for the
most part in terms of the hackington
school district I had to send
notification to parents including at
that time the students in that school
the governor of the state of New
Hampshire information telling them that
motion picture video guidelines for
video games which included at the time a
rash of kids bringing in information
about Grand Theft Auto in which
prostitutes are beaten to death for
points I had to explain to parents that
those types of video games that were in
the hands of their fourth grade students
was
inappropriate so I take offense at the
terminology of people saying that
Educators out there aren't on the
defensive trying to protect students
from unhealthy or unsafe situations we
do it on a daily basis where I take
offense in this this particular
legislation is all around the removal of
the local standard representative
cordelli touts the fact that that Miller
versus uh California was a standard
that's 1972 by the way in case you
didn't know that particular fact you
just ran out of time well and may I may
I up for questions sir I appreciate
you're an intermediate level principal
too at one time I was also and well are
there
questions
do you have written testimony oh
represent Tanner could you explain a
little bit more about um the values that
of the Miller uh certainly the prong of
the Miller that I find the most
challenging and I think that there's a
plethora of literature that's out there
that supports this is the vagueness
standard and there the the Supreme Court
says it the the Journal of New England
law says it and frankly in 1987 that all
of the case law after that found it
particularly challenging to be able to
identify the standards that
representative cordelli built into the
language which I believe is that uh that
whole standard that surrounds the idea
of um of content that has value among
other things um the one thing that I
think that is most important to me if I
if you leave you with no other fact
whatsoever is is that the importance of
that standard for Miller says the same
thing and it says that the community
standard is the value that is one of the
most important prongs that stems from
that decision that the local local
community gets to make the decision
where the value lies but the bill that's
being placed out here in front of us
today absolutely is a it is a false
representation of community value it
simply says that you know what we're
going to put in front of you uh the
ability to challenge curriculum which
already exists by the way under policy K
and many other policies in schools for
individual parents to make individual
rights decisions about their personal
values but when it comes to the
materials in our libraries the materials
in our classroom there is policy it's by
law mandatory and yes to your question
that was asked over here accessibility
to library contents is already in
legislation and almost every school has
a digital format for inter Library loan
information and tracking where those
books are being sent and what the
content of libraries are but when you
take this decision you move it away from
the school principal or the lead
investigator which has to do the
impossible in the first place make that
decision and you move it to a board
which is the elected body and that body
is denied because somebody doesn't agree
with the decision and they move it to a
political body how is that a
representation of the local community
it's not it's the state and in this case
it's a particular political bent of the
state because it's an appointed body
that's making the decision so I ask you
to strongly consider that yes we need to
keep our children safe allow us to do
the work that we do in education the
right way please allow us that but
please leave the decision at the school
board level is the final appeal process
thank you are there further
questions very quick one please um could
you comment on uh We've several people
mentioned the chilling effect on
teachers that even having this bill and
having it go through all the Hoops in in
you know the the house and the Senate
and that sort of thing have on your
ability as a as a superintendent or
assistant superintendent I can and I can
tell you the personal story of me when a
group of individuals as I was doing the
lesson that I was descri ding to the day
after I completed that lesson I was in
my classroom and I have similar stories
I could share with you about modern
classrooms from the years that I was the
principal in this particular situation A
group of parents came into the school
they snuck into the school because they
walked in through the front door there
were about 15 to 20 of them they were
wearing white blouses and black overalls
and hats and they all had Bibles in
front of them and they walked into my
lab and they lined up in a straight line
women in front Men Behind with the
Bibles all open quoting Genesis to me I
was terrified I was 21 years
old and I didn't know what was going to
happen if not for the fact that that
school principal Joe cordelli was
sitting in that office come running down
the hallway saying you can't be doing
this I would have been absolutely
chilled to the fact that I would never
have taught that lesson which by the way
was on human life it wasn't even on
Evolution which was the next
chapter thank thank you Woodcock thank
you chair uh welcome and thank you for
your uh testimony has been terrific than
um and and for your dedication to the
education profession thank you uh you
mentioned that the Miller standard was
1972 Miller California believe was 72
yep okay as 50 some OD years ago uh five
decades half these people weren't even
here uh do you know if that standard has
been uh changed since then I'm not a
lawyer there are people in this audience
who are they can speak to that with far
greater um you know Authority than
myself probably CH be Christina could
tell you that one but I do know this in
in a simple search and research of the
topic the themes that I was able to come
up with based off of the Miller decision
which were predicated by decisions U on
I think it was called Mission or
missionary or something to that effect
of Massachusetts and there was another
one prior to that all of those comments
that came forward say the same thing
when you leave the definitions vague and
you leave the definitions in places
where you don't have that Clarity it
creates that nebulous chilling effect
for teachers and it happens I have
teachers who are refusing to use art in
schools in classrooms dega right now if
or man rather if I want to show you the
picture of Olympia where Olympia is in a
reclined position and her breast is
exposed I'm subject to Mr cordelli or
representative cordell's um
interpretation as to whether or not that
has artistic value that's not fair
because it's going to create a chilling
effect why because the process that's
defined inside this bill doesn't allow
the school board to make that decision
it rests on a political body with a
political bent and so rather than take
the risk and by the way there's a
financial cost to this whether the note
says it or not I as the school
administrator I'm going to employ a
lawyer that's going to cost a lot of
money by the way and if you think that
we're not facing a a situation right now
where frivolous complaints are being
filed I would refer you to the 91a
complaints for Stacks and stacks and
stacks of information that are being put
out because they know and representative
cordelli knows this that by creating the
chilling effect that's in place it's
going to prohibit people from doing it
in the first place because individuals
aren't getting their way because they're
not in alignment with a community moral
standard thank you thank you thank
you no no no no
no further questions thank you very much
you're welcome uh Laura L
aim
no because you've already testified you
can't good morning thank you for having
us here today um I'm from londonairy
Laura Alam I have five kids um couple of
things um I think words are important
and it just keeps going round and round
words have meaning this is this bill
keeping obscene materials out of schools
is no more book Banning than having an
ID check at a at a strip club or at a
night Club it's just something that
reasonable adults have understood for
ages is a fact some materials are okay
for adults but not okay for children um
my children when they grew up there were
things that we discussed at home that we
didn't discuss at schools I never
certainly said to them the only thing
it's okay to talk about is what your
history teacher talks to you about or
what your biology teacher talks to you
about it's my job to talk about all
kinds of things to expand their Horizons
make them better people a lot of it just
doesn't belong in schools and when I
think about the frequent argument that I
keep hearing I just really wish you'd
reject it the idea that there is a group
of people whether they identify with a
certain ideology or whether they've had
certain experiences in their lives that
may have been
tragic that they should identify that
they need to have their identity built
upon an obscene book A book that depicts
very graphically not just biological sex
but all kinds of of really per verted
things and it may not be your opinion
that you're that that's perverted that's
okay but to tell your kid because of who
you are because of who you want to be
this book is absolutely critical to your
identity I think that's a tragic tragic
diminishment of their human dignity and
it really limits their Horizons and I
wish that we didn't have to stake the
happiness of kids or their their
emotional well-being on the existence of
bruant
really truly disgusting books available
to them in the libraries it isn't book
Banning it's just simple responsible
adulthood to say hey you can go down and
get that at Barnes & Noble but it's not
going to be available in the publicly
funded uh Library that's all thank you
very much are you willing to take
questions sure are there any questions
from the
committee not see any thank you very
much thank you a
biset
uh thank you Mr chairman uh members of
the committee thank you uh first time uh
the session for this committee so it's
good to see you all jel B on the legal
director uh of the ACLU of New Hampshire
strongly uh in opposition uh with
respect to to uh this bill and I know
that I have very limited time so I kind
of want to go through my points pretty
quickly but I do think they're they're
very important here and I I do think
that this is a bill really uh in in
search of a problem I haven't seen any
indication today that existing School
District or School Board policies are
insufficient and don't permit book
challenges in fact we have seen book
challenges throughout the state
districts have policies in place to
address these so Community can community
members can raise concerns and those can
be vetted
um so I don't think uh this bill is
necessary to that extent because I don't
think I've heard any real reason to
indicate why those policies are in any
way insufficient or inadequate but I
think more importantly there are
existing laws on the books here and I
just think um it's it's critical to
understand that and even to dive into
what those laws do so on page two of my
testimony I actually recite um not the
entirety but the entire of the chapter
but the entirety of two sections that
our New Hampshire's harmful to miners
statute and that's what we're talking
about here but we already have a statute
that addresses this and that's RSA 571
B1 and 571 B2 and I I just haven't heard
anything today to demonstrate why that
statute's insufficient at all and I
think that is really like the critical
question here um in what ways is that
statute inadequate um and I don't think
it is inadequate in any way and to the
extent that this bill is aimed at um
calling out books or instructional
material that is not covered under
existing law to the extent it goes
beyond that that's actually could uh
create serious constitutional issues um
that I want to walk this committee uh
through but there are uh uh real uh ways
too in which this bill frankly is
actually even more expansive than
existing law which I think is just as
problematic the first is there's no
knowing requirement here um in this
particular
statute um in addition uh as was
mentioned before and I think it's
important to highlight when we talk
about obscenity we're talking about uh
Community standards um this I actually
think um goes beyond that it is true
that there is kind of a complaint
process that's done at the local level
under this bill but it's subject to
appeal by the State Board of Education
what standards are is the State Board of
Education going to be using is it the
community is it the state and the fact
that it's a state board of education I
think highlights a problem with this
which is that the decision at the end of
the day can and should be at the local
level which is consistent with current
practice and I think this uh upends that
Norm and also I do think runs uh
somewhat contrary to the community
standards approach that exists in state
law in addition one way in this statute
is more expansive and potentially in a
prob problematic way is that it targets
more than just sexual conduct it targets
M nudity uh and sexual uh uh excitement
um and I think that does create some
constitutional problems particularly
when you look at the Reno uh versus ACLU
case uh which talks about how from a
constitutional perspective you would
need to limit obscenity to OBEX to
sexual conduct that is not what this
bill does I also do think that this bill
adds a separate standard apart from the
Constitution standard which is the
fourth criteria that represent if you've
gone beyond your time sure the
inappropriate to the age of the minor
standard I just would note exists
outside of constitutional Doctrine this
problematic and lastly this the law is
vague and lastly I think the criminal
piece in section one is really a
different thing altogether it should be
um stricken that also would implicate um
K through 12 private schools as well um
so I just wanted to to flag that
particular issue but that's mentioned in
my testimony thank you thank you very
much are there questions represent
dry thank you and thank you for taking
my question thank you I wanted just
again to talk about school board and the
decision um process because that's part
of due process is to be able to uh take
an appeal a decision between a
individual and a school
system so yeah would you dis take that
part out of the equation then and not
have it in due process be part of the
process oh no I think there's plenty of
due process in fact there there already
would be multiple layers of review right
you go to the superintendent right layer
number one if you disagree with that
that decision you can go to the local
school board I think that is fine and in
fact I think that's consistent with
current current policy I think that is
consistent with due process what I have
added layer of concern about is this
whole separate kind of State Board of
Education process which I think now
takes this out of the community
standards approach which is what we um
we normally how we normally consider
these issues um the the law that I
mentioned 517b is uh I think think is
reflective of that you file you know a
lawsuit could be filed in County court
it's adjudicated by a County judge a
county attorney can also bring a claim
that two is consistent with Community
standards I don't think the State Board
of educ Education piece here
is thank you further questions from the
committee represent whitcock thank you
chairman good morning and thank you for
being here thank you um I was just heing
some CLA I asked the previous speaker
and he knowled I should ask someone more
knowledgeable in law than him and that's
more than me so I'm going to go back to
the middle of 1972 stand um there was uh
a lot that this bill is predicated
on uh are you aware if that law has been
changed to be less vague and more
specific as time is going on I it's I
think it's generally frankly this this
this this current standard um and I
think you have to look at Miller and the
Ginsburg case that represented cordelli
mentioned and kind of that because that
case deals with miners in particular um
those standards as old as they are um
still exist and they're evaluated and
adjudicated at the community level
because communities are are different so
I do view it as the current state of the
law still okay thank you thank you
you're welcome yeah further further
questions thank you very much thank you
Mr chairman I'd like to invite rousan
Chester hi my name is Russ anchester I'm
from Bedford New Hampshire and I would
just like to say yes parents are being
denied to go into libraries um happening
in my town the fact that Michael Strand
who lives in my town sat up here and
said it's not happening is concerning um
the other thing I want to bring out is
the poster that he mentioned um was is
from it was a quote it was put in
writing none of the pictures were put on
that poster it was during polling and um
or during during our election local
elections and one of the words
was s and then it did star star star
k so we didn't even put something on
there so that the kids and they said
well they could all figure it out well
the fact that the parents had the
problem with it at a polling station
means it probably shouldn't have been in
grammar school library
I had a child that went to school in
2005 it was through the health education
she was a sexually reactive child um she
was my stepchild uh sexually reactive
child and uh she wanted she didn't want
to be different she wanted to go through
the sexed class with the rest of her
students I said okay every night when
you come home we will process this the
school not knowing that she was a SE
sexually reactive child because she was
in counseling and she didn't want people
to know um and her counselors supported
that
decision but because she started having
signs and symptoms of a sexually abused
child the school the counselor the
teacher and the administration of that
Middle School took it upon themselves to
file a CPS uh allegation against myself
and my
husband I spent 17 years doing abuse and
neglect investigation and the questions
that they asked my child was not okay
and the fact that we even have to sit
here and say what's too
much do you know 90 97% of autistic
children also identify as lgbtq
Plus
that's huge we're talking about an we're
talking about a population who socially
they may be 12 years old but socially
they may not be and it's not okay every
child should be looked at individually
that the fact that that folks have said
things like we need to trust our
teachers and our counselors well how's
that work for us it is happening in New
Hampshire it is happening in New
Hampshire it's happening in edford New
Hampshire um we know this um one of the
speakers mentioned oh and so that you
know that that that middle school book
was
Lawnboy um that had the poster that they
you are at loed okay um one of the one
of the prior um people talked about it's
harmful to the educator what about
harmful to our children shouldn't it be
shouldn't that's what we be most worried
about is what's harmful to our children
do you have written testimony for no I
don't and just in closing it I keep
hearing we already have the laws there's
plenty of due process well if there is
how come we are having this problem
thank you very much are there questions
from the committee Ron would talk thank
you CH i' just like to respond to a
question she raised the question you
raised the question I'm sorry uh we we
need to trust our counselors and
teachers how's that working out for you
I say work out terrific we a lot of and
teachers to make the decisions so is
there a question the answer hers thank
you can I respond that was your question
you
said can I can I rephrase yes thank you
I was I was a counselor I know there are
great teachers and great school
counselors and great Librarians and
great superintendents and great
principles but the problem is is that I
did sexual abuse and neglect
investigation for 77 years and the
bottom line is those perpetrators will
go where their victims are which is our
schools and that's the bottom line
further
questions not seeing you thank you very
much thank you uh Betsy
Harrington hi I'm Betsy Harrington I'm
from Deering I'm a mom of two boys at
Hillsboro deing High School I'm also
trained as a therapist and I worked as a
sex offender counselor at the prison
just down the street I'm not just a
worried mom here I'm a professional that
has Grave concerns I've seen it for
myself and I can see that boundaries
need to be set we are at the Event
Horizon if we don't set this very simple
boundary now we might not come back this
is the minimum this is literally using
the language from the American Library
Association if we can't agree on this
we've all gone mad this bill would only
be stopping the most blatant of
offensive materials it won't protect
kids from all sexually explicit
materials it would only keep out the
most obvious of overt sexual content
like Penthouse and tri XX this is
content most Educators already agree as
age inappropriate it won't weed out all
the sexual content repackaged for kids
this bill keeps out only the worst it's
a no-brainer even for the liberal-minded
the truth is my kids get promoted a ton
of unwanted sexually explicit content
through their Chromebook books and
libraries I want you all to know that my
kids are banned from using the library
the first time I went to my school board
to complain about the first book I've
ever even gone to a meeting they said
okay your kids can't use Library anymore
and it's been since this been over a
year now that my kids have been banned
from using the library they're the two
top students in their in their classes
but they can't use the library just want
to make sure you all knew that strangely
I can see the sex ed curriculum two
weeks ahead of time and approve or
disapprove yet I can't disapprove of
blatant sex misinformation being
promoted through their their Chromebooks
and their libraries why why can't I
protect my kids for OB sexual content in
school too let me read a few lines from
Juno Dawson's book this book is gay this
award winner reads differently through
the online school library because it
includes a blue hyperlink to adult
dating apps in the section of the book
titled how to use sex apps pay attention
here we are literally hyperlinking our
kids to sex seeking adults through their
online school books we call that sex
trafficking let me quote from that
section where they hyperlink straight to
the sex apps gay and by men have taken
to app sex like ducks to sexy water
technology changes frighteningly quick
the lesbian app Crusher has been gone
already but it seems the market leader
grinder is here to stay how sex apps
work upload a tiny picture of yourself
to the app the app works out your
location the app tells
tells you who are the nearest
homosexuals you then chat with them
because they are near it is easy to meet
up with them meet up with them yes our
school books now hyperlink our kids to
sex-seeking adults for meeting up the
book then goes on to give an exact play
byplay on how to please the adults with
explanations of handies bloes and
bumming you'll have to read the book if
you want to know what that means this
book has a ward on it and is in the
shared New Hampshire collection of the
Sor Student Life Library app it's
promoted to thousands possibly tens of
thousands of our New Hampshire students
if even only one kid clicks through what
does that mean we did excuse me you're
you're out of time I'll finish up
there's only two more sentences this is
so unwelcome to parents it is time we
set some minimum standards around the
sexually explicit materials this is the
minimum this is using their language P
this or we have crossed the precipice
into true depravity there will be no
standards are questions from the
committee represent leus
that book with you which you referenced
is intended for adults um and it's rated
that way so I'm
wondering what age is that available to
students in our schools so that's in the
store student Library this is available
to T tens of thousands of students
around our state 53,000 school districts
in the country use that Sora reading
Library app so it's really why and it's
in our shared New Hampshire collection
so why would that be a shared book in a
collection of a library that has over
8,000 titles why would we have a book
that has a blue hyperlink that
hyperlinks you to sex-seeking adults but
yet it's there and I can show you all
because I have access to the Sora
reading Library app right here on my
phone so what age is that further
questions well the ask re asking the
same question my kids are getting it my
kids are in high school okay thank thank
you very much further questions rep and
dry thank you and thank you for taking
my question are there any like a
parental um guidelines that you can make
on the Chromebook to block things that
are inappropriate no so when I went to
the school for the very first time and
let me tell you I scheduled a private
meeting because I was very embarrassed
I'd never been to a school board meeting
before a teacher posted to the town that
I was going to try to ban books and that
the whole town should come to my private
meeting I was so ashamed and Afraid all
I wanted to do was let them see it that
was it I did not want a big protest and
me to become this lady who I now am
right but I can't stop because I saw it
it's a blue hyperlink to sex-seeking
adults in my kids Chromebook and I can't
turn it off they said it can't be turned
off match.com always blue hyperlink 100%
of the time you cannot stop match.com
from that blue hyperlink so I asked them
to take the book out nope it's in the
shared New Hampshire collection no one
is cultivating that Library I want you
all to know that Sora reading Library
the The Librarians are not cultivating
that Library My Librarian just leaves it
alone it comes from California that's
the librarian that cultivates that
Library we pay $250 a year to get 8,000
trashy books there are zero Steinbeck
books in that library but there are 95
Pokemon books so it's just trash and
this book is gay which has the blue
hyperlink and other books that hyperlink
the kids straight to really bad places
we should not have hyperlinks in our
libraries thank you very much are there
further questions from the committee not
seeing it thank you you deorah
house
good morning good morning chairman lad
members of
morning uh yes we've heard a lot of
testimony already and I will try not to
be repetitive but my name is Deborah H
and I'm the president of the American
Federation of teachers New Hampshire I'm
here to speak on behalf of our 3700
members across the state mostly in uh
prek through 12 public schools and we
are here to oppose hb1 1419 and despite
the impression you might get from
reading the bill or listening to some of
the previous testimony uh the members of
my union are focused on teaching
children to read and write not enforcing
inappropriate books in their hands now
is a time when we should be focusing on
real solutions to make sure that all of
our Granite State Public Schools
students can uh learn to read and write
and thrive in their Public Schools if
they have all the resources need to do
that we should not be focusing on bills
that will divide communities pitting
families against each other and making
making it easier to remove books from
school libraries which will indeed make
it impossible for many students to
access those books in fact it would be a
book bad we have heard a lot of
discussion about the Miller test and
despite the really clear descriptions of
things that would be red flags that I
think we can agree you don't want many
students exposed to the Miller test is
objective and the complaint process
described in this bill would put the
decision making um out of the hands of
local control we have a
long history of local control in our
state and the ultimate irony here in a
state with such a tradition of local
control and individual liberties this
bill would Envision putting the decision
making on what would be inappropriate or
um you know wholly and predominantly
appealing to prian interests first on
the decision making of the principes so
that's one person rather than the whole
Community um and then you could appeal
it up to the state board so you'll be
bypassing policies that are in place
where you involve a whole committee that
could be you know a school board member
a principal a librarian a parent or or
even a larger group that have to read
the book and consider it as a whole we
don't want to forgo policies that are
already in place to consider works on a
whole uh and whether you should keep
them circulating in the collection so
that students can access them because if
a student can't access a book it is
indeed banned and out of their
reach finally and I know these words
will probably be taken out of context
but there are some books in school
libraries that can literally be life
saving for a young person for example a
book about surviving childhood sexual
abuse for a child who has been through
it can be something they really need to
see they may not be ready to talk about
it with anyone else but if they come
across a book like that and read
it they might realize that they're not
alone that someone else has lived
through that experience and that it
gives
them hope it gives them a sense that
they can survive as well so even if a
book is challenging even if it is
something that you would not want your
own child to read it might have a reason
for being in the collection in the high
school library so that a child who needs
to see it has the ability to access
it and if it is not available in the
school library there may be no other
place they can get to it thank thank you
very much and I will be my testimony to
you thank you yes thank you I will
answer if I can but if it's the same
question you've already asked and answer
I Willer but I just want to clarify I'm
sorry okay thank you Mr chair and I'm
sorry to be
repetitive but it's being repeated by
numerous people and the fact is that
these
books are available in other places and
a parent has every ability to access it
if they think their child should read it
on Amazon Barn and Noble even public
libraries so just clarify how then this
is a book b well actually under uh
Miller children have the right to access
material as well so if a child just
cannot get to the library to the public
library because in many places they're
only open a few hours a
week and if the only Library the child
can get to is a school library then how
do they have access to it elsewhere what
if they don't have money to go buy the
book
themselves um then then it is inde De
banned and a parent does have the right
to decide what their own child can read
but they don't have the right to decide
what every other child in the community
can read in and of themselves not just
one parent that's why we have policies
that involve a committee and a community
standard that's what the Miller test is
about thank you yeah represent
leus so do you think it is imp
apprpriate for a high school student to
have access to an adult book which has a
hyperlink
to um a an
app where they can hook up with um
adults that certainly sounds like
something that's inappropriate but I am
not knowledgeable of the accuracy of the
previous uh testifier statement so I am
not going to you know testify that I can
say that is correct but that certainly
sounds like inappropriate
uh ability to to connect through the
book
to uh further on the web so you would
agree
uh are there further questions not
represent
try can you
wait thank you for letting me take this
question um thank you for taking a
question I just want to ask about again
the the appeals process it goes from
Principal to Local School Board to to
the state board if needed either step
can be could be the end point if the the
both parties agree is that
correct as far as I understand from this
bill yeah but um if you're talking about
so you've got a couple things going on
here you've got the Miller standard
which is a community standard so if
you're going Beyond The Local School
Board to the State Board then you're no
longer dealing with a local community
standard and your local school board is
elected by your local community and the
state board's Not Elected so you've
really kind of mixing apples and oranges
now aren't you so my followup question
is if this is due process for any case
why would we make a special case just
for dealing with books that doesn't
follow the due process but you got a
different legal
standard thank you yeah uh further
questions not seeing thank you very much
uh
Beverly
um I can't last I can't read the last
name good luck my name is Beverly Pet
licky I'm a UNH graduate I was an
English
teacher uh secondary English teacher for
six years Public School System I'm also
a master degree librarian University of
South Florida I've worked in public
libraries I've worked in was first the
law library and I've worked in a public
library and worked in a school
library and I'm here
unfortunately Betsy here my friend uh
this is really hard for me really hard
for me because I'm probably sexually
reactive myself but um I'm a
professional and uh I did go to the
Hillsboro school board meeting as a
librarian when I was living in Hillsboro
and I begged on the superintendent I
actually challenged her to uh create a
challenge of materials policy for
Hillsboro which she did and I've seen it
and there I do have a uh I did print
this out for the committee and for Betsy
if you want parents do have the option
to opt out of the Zora app so they they
their children do not have to have
access to the digital Zora app if they
don't want their children to have access
to it also as a libr Li Arian I spoke
with the representative from overdrive
the books on Zora app are curated by a
librarian and there is a
materials consideration policy with
overdrive that the school librarians in
New Hampshire can follow to have those
books removed from the Zora app this
problem is is the school librarians
either don't have a collection
development policy well that's what it
is I'm a public librarian where it kind
of crosses over because I really
honestly feel that the state librarian
should be here
today testifying and he's not and it
really bothers me that he's not here
um I am going to read my testimony and
then I'm I have a copy of the library
Bill of Rights I also need to let you
know that there's a federal law called
the uh children's internet protection
act which was enacted in the year 2000
and anything that's available on the
internet that H has any obscene material
to it at all is a federal
offense so there are existing laws
already but teachers do need to be able
to have compassion and discretion and we
need to be able to
separate
ideas which Library materials book
materials and teacher materials
represent ideas and reality of children
going through sexual abuse which is what
the representatives uh the the C school
counselors have to deal with but this
law will and it has all these problems
with it that the lawyers have discussed
about
local a collection development policy a
library collection development policy
there's a portion of it and it's
available on the American Library
Association toolkit I can give you an a
link to it um I was part of the
intellectual deel your time is my time
is almost up but I was part of the
intellectual uh committee intellectual
Freedom Committee in Florida when I was
working as a public librarian there and
it is made up of community members a div
diverse Community
memberhip which is not being implemented
in in the state I'm just I I have um
submitted my written testimony if my
time is up that's fine I will submit
these paper these papers to the
committee uh I have submitted my online
testimony uh on the online tool for the
state legislature but there's a lot
that's missing here uh and I I feel like
I'm almost even though I'm opposed to
this B bill I feel like I'm testifying
in favor of it and I feel like it's
gotten to this point because people are
not excuse me time is up all right
people are just not aware of the
existing walls already please submit
that written testimony have to the clerk
and it'll be put into the record are
there any questions uh from the
committee I'd like to take questions
represent McDonald thank you Mr chair
and thank you for being here and I'm so
nervous I'll try to word this
sensitively I understand it's a
sensitive topic but could you you please
clarify your statements regarding That
explicit online content is already a
violation of federal law as one of the
previous people who testified mentioned
that um some of these digital apps may
be accessing explicit content online and
other websites may be available at
perhaps a student's fingertips so could
you just clarify where in federal law
may be already a violation yes it's it's
a 47 code of federal regulations 54.5
520 children's internet protection act
certifications required I have a copy of
it here School
library um statutory the term minor
means an individual who has not attained
the age of 17 years the term obscene has
the meaning given as such terms as 18 us
code effect relations 1460 the term
child pornography has the meaning given
such an 18 USC code
2256 the the term harmful to minors
means any picture image graphic image
file or other visual depiction that
taken as a whole with respect to minors
appeals to a puant interest in nudity
sex or
ex I'm sorry I'm an educated person but
I am so nervous about
this excretion excretion depicts
describes represents in patently
offensive way with respect to what is
suitable for minor
an actual or stimulated sexual act or
sexual act actual or stimulated normal
perverted sexual acts or lwd exhibition
of the genitals and taken as a whole
lack serious literary art this you got
this they took you took this probably
from here from this us code of children
protection act you probably took it from
that so we don't need it we don't need
this bill because we already have a
federal Bill may I ask a followup thank
you very much yes thank you and thank
you for that answer and I hope you
provide that as well I mean I I don't
think we should impinge upon the freedom
of a teacher to make these discretion I
think we need to keep this Miller
decision I've never heard of it before
but what I'm proposing is that we follow
the American Library Association
guidelines for collection development
policy which is misleading what the
collection development policy says is
that there will be a local committee
formed who will voluntarily read
whatever challenge material has been put
filled out by the form here
reconsideration of Library materials
form which a parent like Betsy would
have to fill out okay would go to a
committee this committee would read this
material and this committee would make a
decision as to whether or not a local
committee that's a parent a student a
teacher a a Community member and a
school board member five people and they
vote do we keep this material in our
library or in our school curriculum or
not not the elected school board at the
state level okay so I believe that the
that this has been a gross
misrepresentation throughout it's just
been a piece that's missing there I have
worked at I have been in employed at
seven different public libraries the
state of New Hampshire only one library
has had a collection development policy
the policies in the public library in
the state of New Hampshire are lacking
there are Librarians in this state that
do not that are directors that do not
have a master's degree that are not
educated in the fact that these policies
need to be in place I still oppose this
Bill thank you for your time thank you
very much uh bar
Christina you have a
question
that welcome
Barrett uh good morning committee thank
you uh chairman lad uh Barrett Christina
from the New Hampshire school boards
Association um just to be clear um the
school boards Association is not taking
taking a position on this bill uh there
are some things um that we find a little
problematic but there are things that we
think um within the bill that are
workable as well too um I know um I've
got three minutes I've got about 10
points I'm going to try and get to in in
those three minutes um again uh uh no
position on the bill um our our local
school boards um uh nhba members just
last October adopted the following two
resolutions in October 2023 the first
one nhsp ba opposes any legislation that
divests local school boards of original
jurisdiction relative to complaints
about local curriculum instruction and
instructional material instructional
resources such as books library
materials and other instructional
resources further nsba opposes any
legislation that subjects School
District staff to civil La lawsuits and
sanctions relative to curriculum and
instruction that was one resolution
adopted by our members last October a
second corresponding resolution also
adopted last October NH hsba affirms the
qualifications of School District staff
to research and select appropriate
digital and printed materials for
schools literary and curricular
collections should offer students
information that provides a balance of
cultural views further literary
collections should represent diverse
points of view provide a Global
Perspective stimulate essential thinking
skills and meet the interests abilities
learning styles and information needs of
the Learning Community uh so those two
resolutions are the basis of NHS Ba's
testimony um a handful um of the um uh
the the the complaint process outlined
in the bill um we have some concerns
with it but we think that it's workable
perhaps with an amendment um as the
committee may know um representative PA
testified earlier he has House Bill
1311 um and the title of that bill is
relative to school district collection
development and reconsideration policies
um as you this committee may remember we
had a bill last year on this subject
nsba um offered an amendment to
representative cordelli and
representative lad about developing a
complaint process if you will for local
school boards we have to adopt a policy
um that's where nsba has no objection um
adopting a policy for parents to come in
and make a complaint or raise a concern
with a particular course material or
Library material and then some process
of review locally and hsba can fully
support that um the provisions that are
in uh this bill in 1419 about the
specific um uh appeals processed that
representative cordelli laid out it's a
little perhaps too restrictive or too
stringent um than what nsba might
recommend but we think maybe between
representative PA's Bill and this bill
and perhaps some input from uh nhba if
you would like it or looking at other
policies from around the states that
seem to have been um successful maybe um
some bipartisan language can come from
that uh you may also remember when we
had the bill last year I printed off I
think I found policies from maybe eight
or 10 School SCH districts from from
this committee communities that you
represent um I thought there were some
really good ones um within there as well
too I don't know if I still have those
on f file but nhsp is happy to do some
of that research and come back to the
committee um with a a Statewide
perspective of what some other districts
are doing relative to their
reconsideration
policies uh trying to get to the points
made um we would certainly object to the
um the appeal uh to the State Board of
Education at the very least least if
there's going to be an appeal to the
State Board of Education um then the
aggrieved party um from the uh uh the
decision of the State Board should be
able to appeal to the to the New
Hampshire Supreme Court as well too the
other comments that were made about
putting in the hands of sort of
unelected bureaucrats at the state level
that don't represent that community and
hsba certainly rep uh uh uh would Echo
those those uh sentiments um one other
point just that it's a more a
clarification um that I'm not to
um page two line 21 um representative
Cordell you said no the bill States no
later than November 1st
2025 each local school board shall have
a complaint policy I'm wondering if you
meant 24 by that because 25 would be a
year plus out um If This Were to go
through um uh again represent pry I
don't know if you met November 1st of
2024 or 2025 either way 2024 might be a
little bit tight 2025 obviously gives us
a year and a half if we need to move
that up like a January 1 2025 would be
workable as well too and the last point
that I want to make um so uh on page
two line of 17 and 18 no school district
um person employed by a school district
or person who contracts with a school
district shall make available this
material okay so we know it applies to
districts and District employees and
School District contractors however if
we jump to um the enforcement and
penalties provision on page three I'm
inan lines that paragraph starts at line
28 goes down to 34 um I'm reading the
end of line 29 a civil action against a
school or School District in Superior
Court may be filed for legal or
Equitable relief um if we have a
contractor I mean obviously the school
district has an obligation to know what
the contractor is doing as well too
within the school district but the the
the Civil penalty should also apply to
the contractor as well too will not
necess necessarily um only the school
district or only the employee um I think
those are nhs's points thank you for
giving me a couple extra minutes
representative lad um again we're not
taking a position on this bill um the
the the the complaint process NH hsba
has no problem working with this
committee representative paig
representative cordelli to come up with
something that maybe would fit in the
middle um and with that I'm happy to
answer any questions thank you very much
are there questions from the
committee thank you very much for
information with that I'm going to close
the hearing for excuse me Mr chair I did
submit a pink card as well yeah but
you've also asked a question so you're
not going to be able to present by doing
what you did quering my question was not
answered um I did try to ask a followup
but the speaker you engaged as a
Committee Member in the process and then
for you to go out and then come this way
is I appreciate that thank you you're
welcome can I include it in the record
yeah can somebody else can somebody else
read what she was supposed to read that
that's in the record it's in the record
the cards were submitted and that's in
the record so we're going to close this
here
1419 and we're going to be taking a five
minute break
here five minute break and come back and
do the next bill yep time
up okay what do I um so like just just
just get one of those like and I didn't
even know if it's relevant that she
should give me all that lady who the
second last person all kinds of stuff
but she submitted it as part of her I
okay you don't have to question it
justat it in just thought I'd asked it's
sort of
unusual
I
she
$50 million no less than $50 million and
in each time it comes out of this
committee but goes to finance and it's
it's doesn't go any farther and so what
we're trying to do is react to the
sheets which we got from the Bureau of
school safety and Facilities earlier
this year when we had orientation and we
saw the number applications were coming
in for school building Aid we saw the
amount of money which those applications
would incur or cost the the state as
well as locals and we know that of those
applications of the 17 that were
applications which were considered by
the
state we
approved three top two three three three
applications or so and the others didn't
receive anything and so it comes down to
the issue that we are now have a formula
which we have to subtract out of the $50
million as we appropriate each year the
cost of our debt and that subtracts out
and then the remainder is what you can
use for school building AIDS so we have
incurred as when I came in here I've
mentioned many times before we had over
$500 million in debt that we had accured
we have to pay that debt off and we've
been doing that just whittling it down
over the years and but we still have
debt and we won't be done a lot of that
till the year
2041 and and so it doesn't leave the
money available each year of the bium
for new renovation or construction
projects this bill is trying to attack
how we appropriate the money and how
much we appropriate and and and and then
have it available for the applications
consideration by the the department and
the State Board of Education so I want
to walk you through this real quickly
here um this has not is this bill is not
one which is trying to redefine um the
the end product there's some bills which
are going to come through where a flat
amount of money is issued each year to
the districts putting this to uh the
treasury and and then interest is earned
and when it builds up you can do your
renovation project this is not that bill
it has nothing to do with that so in
looking at the bill and if you have 1570
in front of you we can walk through it
and I'll try to go by these sections and
the first one right there is uh Roman 1
and you see 2 3 4 going down the left
hand side of that page within on number
one within the education trust fund a
separate District fund is created so
what we're trying to do now is take and
appropriate in the the state uh
education trust fund a separate fund
that's called the State Building Aid
fund at the end of going down to Roman
two at the end of fy2 the treasure shall
transfer into that fund $75 million from
the FR uh State trust fund to the State
Building Aid fund so we'd have money
placed into the school building Aid fund
that's in the State uh education trust
fund currently and what's right there by
the
fy2 Roman 3 for FY 26 and each
subsequent year
80% of the education trust fund
operating
Surplus would be transferred to this
state building Aid fund so we're
building up the State Building Aid fund
so it's going to be well over aund and
some odd million
do going down to Roman four slipping
down that page the State Building aid
funds used will be used for spilling Aid
to school
districts and charter
schools so the applica the application
the money for new projects would come
out of that uh state fund which is in
the uh that is that's been separated out
it's within the education trust fund but
it's a separate fund
Within part the second thing it would do
is develop and support the 10-year plan
which we have talked about but we've had
no way of of of uh supporting that plan
and costing how much that would cost
this would delve back into it and
containing the potential for building
Aid projects this 10-year plan is a plan
as you may recall that we've talked
about in the past where we're trying to
get a better handle on what's out there
in the field in terms of of our
facilities and what condition those
facilities are in so we as a general
court can better forast where we're
going in the next 10 years in terms of
Appropriations and basing that forecast
BAS based upon the needs we discern that
in that um 10-year plan and lastly
monies from that building uh Aid trust
fund could be used for the
administration of this program that we
currently have the the um 10-year plan
and and management of of the of the
building Aid projects Roman four five
I'm going through quickly here I know it
the the earning or the interest from the
fund placed in the building a fund those
those that money goes right back in the
fund it's not co-mingled with the back
into the education trust fund any
interest that's gained by the money
that's been put aside in this building
Aid fund stays there the interest goes
back into that fund and the fund is
non-aps other words monies which are
appropriated they're non-aps they
continue to be used for the purpose they
were designed for in Roman 6 uh going
down the page AG here we're going down
on line 19 now the department May retain
up to 3% of the total annual
appropriation and interest for
administration of the program so that
there's a way of building in support to
manage an administer program and that
says up to so somebody might say well 3%
of $100 million you know no it's up to
and that would have to be figured out
through ruem Etc which is in this
bill no building Aid money and Roman 7
seven there shall be used for approv
projects prior to July 25 we want the
money to acrew to include use for Debt
Service payments other words the money
which slides into that immediately would
not be able use use to pay off debt we
want to build up that trust the building
Aid fund so that the monies will be
there to absolutely support the
allocation of $50 million each year for
new construction and construction not
paying off old
debt um going into section two of the uh
the bill here where it says 1898 15a
Romans
4-5 as amended
the under a there a uh School building
Aid grants noer grants approved for
construction renovation by your state
board shall not exceed $50 million per
fiscal years that remains pretty much
the same as where we've been uh and it
also goes in in reads Grant shall be
funded from Appropriations from the
building Aid fund as referenc in this
legislation within the state operating
budget so any grant grant aids for
building Aid have to come out of the
school building Aid
fund um the reference to the 10-year
plan I'm sliding through this very
quickly on page two now where you see uh
Roman five at the Top Line 20 line three
the department shall develop and
maintain a 10-year school facilities
plan we have that in place right now
that a lot of this language is there
it's in current law um and that that's
trying to identify the potential for
projects and projects include but not
limited to criteria there's a criteria
for these projects to be in the 10e plan
and I've written them down in the sheet
that you have there's a whole lot of
criteria that's in 1 9815
C2 B and those are already in place in
law so we would use the same criteria
that's established right now the intent
of the 10e plan is to identify enhance
school facilities to provide safe
healthy and efficient buildings that
provide adequate learning environments
and we know that we have aged buildings
in the state right now well over half of
them are are over 50 55 years old some
of them are so old that they haven't had
Renovations either and as in this
building right here there was much heat
this morning and that's because we have
an Antiquated system up above the fourth
floor in the
Attic yeah I agree with you then going
down in the bottom of that sheet on the
back side that I handed out to you the
State Board shall develop Rules pursuant
to
541a This is a plan this is a whole
rewrite of how we fund an appropriate
dollars for school building Aid and this
will take a lot of our attention in
terms of studying and Reporting I'm not
necessarily looking at something to come
out immediately on this one this is an
area that we've tried to appropriate
dollars and try to go up no less than
$50 million no more than $50 million and
it Remains the Same and we're still
dealing with that debt and our debt is
whittling down it is whittling down so
there' be more each year but we need to
get on it we can't let some of these
buildings such as the one that was uh
next line down in the uh uh approved
projects the conquered situation we're
getting now into some larger buildings
we're up getting an extreme cost of $70
million projects and that's more than we
allocate in a given year and of course
the state share would be a certain part
of that but we're going to get some
larger high schools coming in here and
needing support unless we do something
about how we appropriate dollars how we
allocate these dollars out it's it's
going to it's it's a a tsunami coming at
us and we have to do something about
this and this bill itself is uh offering
a new process for doing this and I'd
recommend that we consider it within the
committee whether it be through an inal
study or some something such as that
right off there's not time in the next
two or three weeks to do that but this
is something that then we couple it with
what's going to be coming over from the
senate in terms of a a process there
where is a flat amount given to each
School each year put it in a trust fund
and and let it acre there's a lot of
issues with that as well so the whole
issue building aid needs to be studied
thoroughly thank you very much I'll
conclude my testimony I know it's
lunchtime questions uh representative U
dry thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
chairman um is this kind of designed to
give more schools money or fewer schools
more money or a combination of both it
wouldn't change that allocation for
example if you're in a district you got
a 60% right now of the you know the
portion which is approved it will
continue the same as that what we're
trying to do is uh build up so we can
get that debt into another column so we
can start uh allocating $50 million out
to these schools uh now this plan also
allows for other grant money can be used
if there's grant money from comes in
from some angle you can couple that with
this but uh it's primarily not trying to
change the whole process where you have
to submit your application by certain
date it's looked and reviewed by the
department it goes to State uh School
building authority and then to the state
board and and then you have to have your
select board or select your town
legislature has to approve the project
we've changed all that application
process that all remains in place we're
not messing with that at all what we're
looking at is the Appropriations we want
to get more money into a separate fund
and it's a non-aps fund in which we can
build our address our 10year plan and
this it's very that's a very important
part of this right here where we right
now we encourage districts to have a
10-year plan we need a 10-year plan we
need to have a contracted service a
vendor go out and assess these buildings
with the same criteria for all our
buildings not just somebody within the
district saying well here's our
application and here are our priorities
and we built it upon this certain
criteria and varies from District to
District um for us to plan and
appropriate properly we need good
information and the department simply uh
with all the good people they have over
there a lot of respect for the the gal
sitting behind me but it's a she needs
help and the department needs help in
really meeting these needs I see school
building ID as the fourth leg of the
stool we have a curriculum alignment
assessment and buildings you can't teach
chemistry if you don't have a room or
space available to teach it in thank
you R wock thank you
re thank you um taking this bull by the
horns here I just have a a question I'm
a little lost on um one of the questions
I'm lost on on the first line 2223 when
you're talking about the uh not the
building projects Pro will not be pried
July 25 so my question
is if one of the multiple school
districts today that have submitted to
the state have been approved but they
didn't fall that one two three we have
and they say number 17 does that mean
that even though they're 17 now and
approved they won't be eligible to
participate in this because they've been
approved previously the buildings which
have been approved and of course Amy
Clark will be here that list is there
and it exists and that's not going to
change we're going to work down through
that list I understand this okay I'm
misreading that because I'm on the same
line I'm misreading it then because said
it can't be used for building projects
approved prior to and so if they last
year $50 million that's placed in that
trust fund can't be used prior that date
we have appropriated dollars for the
bium we're in okay all right thank you I
understand you're saying and and those
technical like things we have people
behind us with technical support so we
can ask those thank
you thank you um it is my understanding
that the building aid program is
struggling because of the debt that they
have so is there anything in this bill
that would prevent the student um
building Aid fund from taking out a
Federal loans the debt issue is not
compounded anymore it STS right in this
bill it's not used for debt so the we
the I believe the idea in this is to
have the debt paid off through monies
which are not the $50 million which is
appropriated for the purpose of
renovation and construction there' be
more money in this building uh trust
this fund then is necessary for just the
$50 million and that would be where the
money would come out to pay debt and I
believe that's like what $6 million or
so each by any or more than that but
we're getting it's it's whittling down
um we had a remember we we had the
information provided to us by the the
department
and they're sitting behind me but um
right we can ask yeah you can ask you
know the debt is right there yes you can
see what the numbers are uh
so ask that ask the technical stuff
behind me please I'm I'm the messenger
Miler no thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question so if I
understand this we have the 50 million
dollar that's already been allocated to
the general fund correct right and this
is an additional amount of money that
comes at the end of the year from um the
bance go into the fund that's the
Surplus money from the trust fund so it
creates a second fund within the
education trust
fund so you got basically two funds that
are going to be providing uh School
building Aid one no you you have we're
taking money out of the education trust
fund and put putting into this fund
within the education trust fund so the
money's going over there and it then it
it is protected
money and what will the new money be
used for
then the educ for construction and
renovation only separate from the
original $50
million that this will be the $50
million I
understand it's coming out of the trust
fund to be transferred into there and
everything for new construction will
come out of that new building Aid fund
so are we creating then a fund that's
going to have what uh 50 plus
75 in subsequent Years first year we put
in 75 million subsequent years you put
80% of the Surplus which is left over at
the end of the fiscal year into that
fund 80% of the leftover money which
would have gone into that trust fund
would go in to the building Aid fund
this is where you're going to get the
money to support the construction that
we
need thank you yeah any further
questions oh thank you very much uh
representative lad and uh Amy
Clark
CH oh my watch isn't working good
afternoon uh I'm Amy for the record my
name is Amy Clark and I'm with the
Department of Education the Bureau of
school
facilities I'm Caitlyn Davis I am with
the Department of the director of the
division of Education analytics and
resources uh director Davis is joining
me because a lot of this is uh money
related and she's the expert in that so
uh happy to take any questions and I can
uh that you'd like uh questions for uh
either uh representative McDonald uh
thank you I just had a question about
the debt and the tail as if you will um
would the $50 million be used to pay off
debt or would it just be reserved for
buildings and not debt use that's a good
question in the um bill online on page
one on line
27 uh that language is crossed out where
it says less any Debt Service payments
um owed in the fiscal year so it's my
understanding that 50 million will be
transferred to the building Aid trust uh
new fund that's created that's not going
to include the debt service so that Debt
Service would still have to be paid for
just like it is now with an
appropriation okay and then just a
follow-up question briefly um the debt
that already exists it is my
understanding was caused from primarily
a Federal Loan is there anything in this
that would prevent perhaps another loan
from being taken out for the debt to
increase um the do you want to answer
that so um that wasn't a debt from a
Federal Loan it was from a state loan
taken out and I I think I believe
2010 uh and that um the language that
prohibits that practice is still in this
bill I believe it's
maybe page um page two line one uh and
line two that language exists now and it
remains now it prevents the state from
taking out a loan to pay that down that
debt and that debt will be paid off by
2030 and representative Vlad was correct
it's about $6 million a year it gets
lower towards towards the end thank you
that answers my question it's a good
question thank you represent Tanner
thank you um so I'm going to play the
age card and say I'm still confused
about where all this money is is coming
and going so 50 million is coming from
the general fund to the building Aid
right so I I think go into the building
I I think um we're completing two
different concepts here so we have money
that can be be made available for
building Aid and then we have building
Aid expenditures we have the revenue and
expenditures this bill is more dealing
with the revenue side of things so this
bill is basically saying there's
leftover money in the education trust
fund rather than letting that money just
stay in the education trust fund and
building up in the education trust fund
create a sub account and put that money
there that can be specifically used for
building Aid and then separately you
have the building aid program which this
bill doesn't change the building aid
program it has $50 million a year up to
$50 million a year that can be
appropriated to building Aid and so now
once you want to as a legislature
appropriate money for the building aid
program you would take it from this
essentially bank account rather than the
other bank account and that's kind of a
common question that comes up every
single year when you're talking about
appropriating money for building Aid
we've seen bills over the year to change
it to a minimum of $100 million a year
$60 million a year reduce it but the
question always is is where is that
money going to come from now we have an
answer to that question the money would
come from the school building Aid fund
and it would be there sitting there
ready to go for projects at the time
that you were ready to allocate the
money you have a follow up on that go
wait yes so okay so um once this fund is
set up once once the 80% of the Surplus
is set up no longer will any money come
out of the general fund that will go
towards building AIDS so the um Debt
Service would still continue to be paid
out of the general fund but that's it um
out of the general fund correct okay and
the my other question on this bill is
that one more I'm sorry I'm sorry Mr
shair um is that right now charter
schools are not part of the building Aid
Pro program is that correct so charter
schools are in the building Aid law but
then there's another law specifically in
the charter school law that prevents um
charter schools from receiving building
Aid so this leaves the building Aid law
the same which still identifies charter
schools and says Charter Schools can
receive 30% but it does not impact the
other Charter School law so you would
still need to remove that language from
RSA 194b to enable charter schools to
receive building Aid that's what that
other bill is that we're dealing with
right right but this is exactly the same
as the existing building in language
okay thank you Caitlyn
woodcock
good good afternoon um thank you I'm
going to ask a same question I asked
represent of lag I'm still lost um so
looking lines 22 and 23
if I'm on page the first part of the the
act right
if okay yes yep um today my school is
approved but they're down here in the
list I'm ining this to say since they've
already been approved prior so this is
that they will not be able to eligible
to use this money in the future is that
correct that's not the intent um your
question is a good one um because we can
make a clarification but projects aren't
actually approved until they have been
selected for building Aid they've
approved their warrant article but there
is an approval list so I can see how
that you're that is confusing the intent
is to say you're constructing in fiscal
25 you become approved you still have to
come back to the Department of Education
there's documentation that we need
before we approve you uh and so even
though there's a list of 17 only two
projects on that list of 17 have been
approved so far um one more potentially
will be approved next year uh those are
our approved projects but we could make
a clarification because somebody could
look at that and say well you have an
approved list those are approved
projects thank you thank you chair Kell
represent Miler thank you Mr chair thank
you for being here this obviously is a
an age-old question as far as how we get
money to build schools uh but as I
understand it this is from
surplus of the education trust fund as
long as we have the Surplus correct
that's correct so if we don't have a
surplus then we have to go back to
request for the general fund correct
that would be correct okay the final
question is we have before us a major
education funding bill MH uh should that
become law how would that bill impact
this bill as far as availability of
resources um so if there's less funding
available in the education trust fund or
if there's less of a surplus then less
money would be available to go into the
building Aid fund so that could impact
that this so are you saying that the uh
the adequacy aid has priority over the
building Aid so because adequacy is
always paid first and then whatever is
is left over after adequacy career and
Tech education uh State special
education Aid whatever is left out of
all of those other categories that
becomes that Surplus amount and so that
Surplus amount if you obviously increase
those other accounts then that Surplus
amount becomes less and the SLS would be
thank you for that thank you for that
clarification any
further uh representative
Ford thank you m thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question I don't
fully
understand the expenditure process on
this and I'm wondering at what point is
money actually encumbered or fixed for a
specific project so I hear a lot of
approvals but I've worked in
construction for a long time and I know
you pay for things in stages and so I'm
warning about when the money goes out at
that time and then how is that kept does
it just go out of the fund and we wait
till we get more money in the fund or
does each one have to be renegotiated
each
time uh sure so what happens is um we
have a list of those 17 projects
somebody gets um the top rank project
they go to their voters the voters say
yes for example the voters say yes they
have to then start the process of final
plans in construction you know you're
we're just at the preliminary stages and
so then they have to go through a lot of
work before they see any money from the
Department of Education however we have
that money there we've awarded them that
money uh and then once they have their
proper documentation in they present it
to the Department of Education uh they
show us that the State Fire Marshall has
approved their plans that the they have
the local match to um meet the rest of
the project needs uh at that time we
issue 80% of their award upfront um and
then they can use that to pay for their
project uh you're right they probably
have had uh other Pro other uh
expenditures that they've had to already
en encumber on their end um and then
from there we take that remaining 20%
and then this then we encumber it the
state encumbers it and holds it until
that their project is complete before we
pay it thank you very much welcome
representative T thank you I know you
don't have a crystal ball uh to bring
predict the future but um based on and I
know that the Surplus right now some of
it's due to the the money we got in from
Co and federal monies right the why it's
so high but what do you predict is going
to be higher the 50 the current 50
million from the general fund or do you
think uh the the history of surpluses is
going to give us more money from that so
I just want to clarify that this bill
doesn't talk the $50 million is the
expenditure side of things so it doesn't
matter how much money is in this fund
you would still need to appropriate that
money regardless and there's nothing
that would prevent the legislature from
appropriating additional money if there
wasn't necessary like that Surplus money
or paying it out of the the general fund
or anything like that none of those
mechanisms are changing all this is
doing is putting a set essentially
starting a savings account that is
specifically for building Aid um
the existing Surplus you're right it
absolutely can change and and you know
based on the various different proposals
in the legislature last year from the
house they had changed the um the
revenue going into the education trust
fund so they had had a substantially
less um or or had planned to have
substantially less of a surplus than
what ended up ultimately getting passed
because the Senate changed that back and
the revenue sources and whatnot so
there's a lot of science behind the
revenue side of things too but we don't
believe this changes other anything
other than essentially just starting a
savings account so we can say all right
well let's look at the savings account
when we're talking about building
projects and then that project process
that Amy just described um hasn't
changed all that's exactly what's in law
and that's what will continue to be
followed any further questions seeing
none thank you very much for being here
and with that we'll we'll close the uh
the hearing and we'll uh go to lunch um
Mr chair
uh we're scheduled to be back at
12:45 for the next bill um why don't we
make it
[Music]
1:00
thank you Mr chairman and honorable me
members of the committee uh my name is
Christine Perez I'm from London Derry
Rockingham district 16 I'm here to
discuss and seek your support for House
Bill 1216 relative to cross District
bullying the purpose of this bill is add
to the language of uh RSA uh
193f to include cross districting
bullying and cyber billing to Define
which district would be held responsible
in this type of a case um the district
that would be held responsible would be
the District of the
perpetrator um I've distributed two
documents to you one in support of the
bill from sack the new New Hampshire
State advisory committee with
recommendation of osterath and the
second to um the second is from a
retired Pro professor and now um
president of Change the World send a
child to school uh Dr Brown became very
active in um education committees in
multiple States and he was somewhat
involved with the um episode that
brought this bill forward which I will
go into um this started there with two
districts towards the north um profile
District in Bethlehem and White Mountain
District in Whitefield
um a bullied female uh attended White
Mountain and the male perpetrator was
from profile um the male from profile
found out from his cousin that there was
a Honduras young Honduras woman girl in
the school and so he told his cousin in
profile about it and the um profile mail
sent bullying Snapchats to the and
messages and I
quote and this is just part of it
calling her the n-word a telling
her that her private parts smelled and
that she should just kill
herself um there were three hearings on
this one with the principal a second
with the superintendent and a third with
the school board yet profile maintained
that they had no responsibility for
this um they had no responsibility for
that male's action because it occurred
cross District
District um Dr Brown appealed to the
Department of Education step Berwick and
an administrative judge was appointed to
review the matter they ruled that
profile was legally
responsible and incorrect that they did
not think they were because the
legislation is to protect all children
from bullying therefore schools cannot
prevent bullying just in their own
district and they need to a followup um
profile finally admitted wrongdoing
hence the bill districts are vastly
unreported bullying the Pew research a
nonpartisan think tank out of Washington
estimates that only
34% of parents when their children are
um bullied reported bullying is once
again on the rise and according to the
Department of Education in
201920 with
174,000
707 children School children, 1450 were
reported inance and of these 252 were
cyber bulling now in 21 to 22 with
12,763 less students in the state cyber
bu bullying was up to
1698 bullying incidents reported with
290 being cyber I stress the word report
reported because they are so
dramatically under
reported I urge you to move this bill to
a to pass take the guesswork out of who
is responsible when cross District um
occurs to protect the children that are
being bullied
um any
questions questions
from thank you thank you representative
for being here um so if I'm correct it
was a male student at profile correct
that was cyber bullying a young female
at White Mountain corre Regional okay
and follow up yes follow up please and
that the profile
School uh did not want to investigate
the incident correct felt they had no
responsibility to do that because it was
in another District thank you
uh thank you and thank you for coming um
could you give us an idea how much this
cost in legal costs when all the dust
had settled to the taxpayer it cost over
$48,000 that the young lady who was in
the receiving
School what's she didn't she have to
call her parent andent had to remove her
from she was out of school for two weeks
um she was so distraught at this you
know um um she's at a disadvantage
because of some language barriers to a
certain extent but certainly understood
exactly what was being said to her and
um yes she had did have to remove her
from school F questions from the
committee
thank you thank you for taking my
question
so why was a school responsible did it
happen in school with school property
what what was the school connection to
the cyber bullying um it's my
understanding that it was a Snapchat it
was done on school property but if you
um if you actually read the law the law
says that anything that is
done um and could have been done on
school property computers but anything
that is done that interferes with a
child's education and this interfered
with her dramatically interfered with
her education okay thank
you thank you Mr chair um and thank you
for this bill and this testimony um it
struck a uh a thought when I first read
it and I thought I had read something
out of the Supreme Court recently um
that would speak to this so I've just
looked it up and we have a decision out
of the United States Supreme Court uh
coming in June of 2021 regarding um the
ability of schools to enforce any sort
of speech on students outside of the
school and according to this opinion it
says that certain interests can cause
student or schools to be able to
regulate but when it specifically comes
to bullying it says that the bullying
must be of a severe
nature uh further when it comes to um
its effects on the school environment
the Supreme Court doesn't say um they
they don't say it disrupts a child's
education they say it must materially
disrupt the
classroom environment in order to meet
the criteria necessary to regulate
student speech outside of school so I'm
I'm wondering do you actually think
given that opinion out of the Supreme
Court from 21 that the provisions in
this bill and existing law on regulating
um this bullying might be overly
broad it's my understanding that our
legislation on this says if it disrupts
a child's
education um so I think you know I if
you want to go by federal law or you go
by state law R specifically says
disrupts the education of a child it's
my
understanding thank you chairman good
afternoon just just a question um on the
bottom of the U project two questions
actually the first one is uh uh the only
part that you modified is that which is
in bold is that accurate correct okay so
if I can go to the part I was asking
about on 21 uh actually the last part of
2122 is there a reason that you um made
it specifically for the U the where the
action originate is responsible for the
investigation does that preclude the
other school from doing it no it doesn't
prude the other school but it says who
has
responsibility
see thank you so who required to do it
but the other school may also
investigate at the same time absolutely
okay thank thank you very much thank you
CH thank you
um was the police or any civil uh law
enforcement involved in this because it
was in two different
districts I'm sorry I do not have the
answer to that question
thanks thank you thank you for taking my
question I I think buen is one of the
most horrible things I'm a retired
middle school guidance counselor so I
know I know Bine but I I want to think
that we passed a law a few years ago
restricting the investigation abilities
of school administration of student
social media accounts or am I making
that
up I I don't know if you know but I'm
I'm I'm thinking because I I I want to
say that like the administrators used to
be able to pull up a student's Facebook
account say oh yeah they are bullying
but I thought we passed a law saying
that they were no longer able to do that
so I was wondering how how you would go
about investigating something like this
represent yeah I um yeah I I believe it
was representative bomes bill um that he
worked with a number of agencies on um
and I I think the problem became um Can
the school ask for the students password
to get into their social media accounts
so I'm not I don't I I don't believe it
passed but um it we've had several bills
about social
media
question thank
you
my name is Mora Ryan and in case you
don't know my name I brought my own
tent um I'm here to support this bill um
I wanted to stress that bullying and
cyber bullying is not adequately managed
by schools because typically they're
only required to generate a report which
is not sufficient because the families
and the students who are affected by
cyber bullying it's pretty intense um
negative impacts of bullying include
poor academic Performance Health um poor
health poor social life it often leads
to students leaving school and not being
able to return um I've advocated for
parents in many situations with bullying
and bullying is one of the things that
our schools just don't seem to have a
handle on at this point and the
unfortunate side effect of buling is of
course that children who are bullied
don't necessarily grow up to be
compassionate to other people around
them and they tend to promote the cycle
and Bully other people as adults um and
it's not just the kids who bully it's
the people who stand by and let it
happen and don't do anything about it in
our society we say that we're all equal
and we have to mean that and we have to
say you can't bully other people because
we're all equal and we all have a right
to be um
I support this bill for maintaining
accountability standards for trying to
stop cyber bullying and to protect
children to your point um representative
beler the Supreme Court did say in the
Randy W case that the protection of
children is above all first and foremost
an affirmative duty of the
schools um in addition to
which at this point you know my town I'm
from London der we had an investigation
done against our cheerleading squad and
the parents came forward because the
student committed suicide and when
you're being Cyber Bullied on top of
bullied in school it's a lot to handle
because you don't have a safe space so I
absolutely 100% support this bill I'm
happy to take any questions but I did
also want to point out um too that
bullying tends to lead to psychological
escalation particularly when it's of a
sexual nature and can lead to things you
know like aggravated assault and other
elements so I do think it's something we
need to nip in the bud I think our focus
should be on protecting students first
and foremost and any questions I'd be
happy to
answer questions from the
committee thank you and thank you for
your testimony um besides action of
Investigation do you feel that schools
should also do education around working
with others and and what bullying does
and offer help on that end I do know
that many of the schools have adopted
the Choose Love program which has a
focus on that and I certainly do know
that they're making steps to incorporate
that as part of the curriculum
yes I'm worried a bit by the fact that I
didn't hear
any community resp response to this kind
of a bullying and and I just going back
on my own background uh there would have
been a considerable response even
schoolyard
bullying uh I happened to be a judo
coach and I taught my daughter Judo and
when she was physically bullied on
campus in grade school she threw him on
his keer right in front of the public
and told him next time it would hurt you
know so you know that some of the things
are dealt with more simp of course cyber
bullying adds an extra wrinkle but I
can't help but think that in the
communities I grew up in that person
would have been
shunned and and there would have been a
communal response to that kind of
behavior and I wonder if just the sort
of anonymity of on the net protects them
in that regard or or has the has the
communal consensus on bullying
changed
I think the communal consensus I'm sorry
excuse me I have allergies so I think
the communal consensus on bullying has
somewhat change because I think it was
handled by the community in the past and
I think that one of the elements that
did change it was the
litigiousness of what's going on now I
don't know if you've ever seen the movie
Mean Girls um but Mean Girls is sort of
an example of where bullying is in
effect and when the Parents try to
address it and the woman who wrote it is
actually a psycholog olist and she wrote
up a follow-up book to that which was
called Kingpin dads and queen bee moms
and that addresses the behavior of the
parents specifically because they tend
to come out and say my child did not do
this and they don't take accountability
so I do think that that has been a shift
in society I would agree with that and I
commend you for teaching your daughter
to defend herself I think that's a
wonderful
thing
question thank you very much thank
you
not a problem thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee uh for the
records my name is uh Sebastian Fuentes
I'm the political director for rights
and democracy of New Hampshire but I'm
not here in front of
on that capacity I'm here uh to testify
and support this bill because I was uh
one of the that's the first one of the
parents that helped this family up in
the North Country uh I was one of them
uh the members of the community that
this family reached out for support uh
because they didn't know what to do uh
you know there's there's a language
barrier uh there's also uh the fear uh
just to answer Mr uh representative
for's question uh why the community
didn't do anything it was a desire of
the the bigtim not to share this because
they are a a a refugee family from
Honduras they didn't want to uh cause an
alarm in the community because of uh you
know of a local support to see how the
community is going to respond to it uh I
listen to those videos I watch those
videos and I listen to those audios left
by this student from profile to this uh
student at the W original and it was it
was demoralizing it was impactful to me
uh to see the amount of of hatred that a
young person can uh you know uh Express
to another child uh at the same time it
just kind of brought to my attention now
that in modern days uh many students
have a cell phone and the access to
social media is really uh you know it's
mainstream um my son for example he goes
to the littleon school district and he
has friends uh due to sports and to
social media in like the conquer area
Manchester area uh you know contacts
that he had never have before and
contacts that back in the day when I was
going to high school I was unable to
connect with people so far away so the
fact that now they have uh cell phones
it makes it do Communications across
districts and other areas uh more uh
faster uh again when I heard this it was
uh when I heard those video when I watch
those videos and I listened to the audio
it was definitely uh uh impactful uh and
I personally don't think that the
profile School District
sa35 did a good job of managing uh the
actual um if I I send you actually also
I just submitted an article that was
published this morning by the Caledonian
record uh which actually highlights in
detail the the process and what's
happening up in up in the district uh
one of the uh comments that uh that I
don't think are on this testimony
provided by father Larry Brown uh to you
guys is that the girl the victim was
actually cross-examined by the profile
attorney School uh Barbara lman in
violation of a state administrative law
the attorney suggested that this girl
was not being truthful even though the
boy Snapchat messages to the girl were
available at evidence and again I have
those videos I have those uh you know
those audio recordings uh if anybody's
interesting I don't know what's that you
know that's permissible in this
committee to share but uh I'd be more
than happy to to to share with some
members of this committee and again uh
if you have any questions I'm here
because I was one of the the families
that what family members uh in the
community that was really involved uh
helping this family navigate those uh
that that specific crisis uh that to me
is is is definitely detrimental for her
mental health for uh her educational uh
you know um performance so yes if you
have any questions I'll be more than
happy to to see if I have any answers to
you for yes sir am I
correct in understanding
that am I correct in understanding that
profile was advised by their attorney
that this was not uh an issue which they
needed to address due to the fact this
is a cross District bullying incident uh
that I do not know sir uh what do what I
do know is that the attorney the the
school attorney uh cross examined the
student the victim and found her to be
uh not telling the truth even though all
those messages and the proofs were on
you know on on record on the phone uh
and uh the bigtim show that to the
attorney uh that I do not no thank you
further questions represent Ryan then
represent whitcock thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for coming and giving us
your testimony um in your opinion does
this change help prevent something like
that from happening again yes thank
you firstes thank you Mr chairman thank
you for being here what was the final
resolution uh to this
issue as you can see on the on the
testimony I submitted and also the
testimony that uh Professor Brown
submitted to the committee uh there was
a settlement in the uh School District
between the school district and uh the
uh excuse me I have it right
here uh profile School District ended up
paying 4 48,000 in fees to the attorney
uh and that was pretty much a settlement
that they were going to take care of the
case afterwards uh but to this day there
hasn't been any any work around that um
there's actually a meeting on the school
District today up in the North Country
uh I don't know what what the outcome of
that's going to be but um this is an
issue that hasn't been addressed
properly to this date follow up please
yes uh was there counseling or any other
support for the uh student that was
being bullied I do not know sir thank
you it was mostly uh uh Professor Brown
it was myself again this family is uh
you know uh there's some language
barriers uh they don't know how to
navigate really well the uh you know
theol schol administrative procedures so
they they seek help and uh you know I'm
just a parent you know I'm just parent
of of four kids up in the school system
uh up in the north country and uh in a
way I know a little bit about it and I
have the advantage I can uh communicate
with those folks thank
you represent talk thank you and uh
thank you represent half of what
represent asked was mine as well um but
but I want to follow was there any
determination or what was the
adjudication of the youngster and
profile profile was found responsible
this has from what you're saying and
representative Perez said earlier there
was a settlement paid I'm understand
that but what specifically happened to
the student uh that was doing the
bowling do we know that no sir no we
don't know that we don't know that
information thank you thank you chair
you're welcome any further further
questions thank you very much thank you
are there any other folks here that want
to speak to this
bill of the two people who spoke earlier
represent press and Miss
Ryan are either of you familiar with or
aware in statute it says specifically
each school district and Charter Public
School shall
provide going down to educational
programs for pupils and parents in
preventing identifying responding
to and Reporting bullying cyber bullying
do you know in fact if the district
we're talking about has a policy in
place and how to
respond to
bullying I do not but my focus was on
the fact that we needed to make sure
that this doesn't happen again and that
a school district really tries to take
to is forced to take responsibility as
opposed to I mean what this young woman
went through I mean this went from the
principal a hearing with the principal
to the
superintendent to the school board and
they all denied that they had any
responsibility for this so um it's my
understanding in that um I think perhaps
heads might roll at the school district
meeting tonight but my focus was really
on just making sure that this doesn't
happen again it was a horrendous thing
that this family had to go through and I
think basically because of the fact as
it was stated that there was a language
barrier and there is the inability to
know how to navigate through the system
they were at definitely at a
disadvantage as as well so so I'd like
to go one more step there I'm talking
about profile now I'm going to talk
about white mountain right and White
Mountain obviously had a youngster
that's enrolled in their school that had
to be taken home by Mom due to an
emotional issue right and a bullying
bullying right what did White Mountain
do they should have also a program in
place to address situ situation such as
this do you know if I do not but I do
know that I think it was a little um he
you're responsible he's responsible
you're responsible he's responsible he
said she said yeah yeah yeah okay
represent Cordell yeah if I could just
mention that um I did have a call um
when this first started from uh uh Dr
Brown um who had been told to contact me
by the uh commissioner and Mr Brown told
me that um the uh the commissioner had
talked to the uh profile district and
was told that there was uh nothing in
statute that would require them uh to um
to investigate the case and um thus the
Genesis um for this uh
Bill okay just a little bit more
information I don't have any more pink
cars and doesn't look like anybody else
has a desire to speak on this so we're
going to close this
hearing oh it's getting warm in here
good boy they really turned it
up yeah thank you
jenek exactly right tomorrow
tomorrow okay we have the next bill on
the docket
here I'm looking at the right sheet
1164 1164 which is relative criminal
record checks of teachers credentialing
app app that's my bill yeah
yes see you
too see you
thank
you feel
good
so this will be hearing on HP 1164
relative to criminal records checks of
teachers teacher credentialing
applicants and I will call on the prime
sponsor uh representative
lad thank you very much uh
representative cordelli and members of
the education committee for the record
my name is Rick lad I come from ha New
Hampshire uh Grafton County and I'm here
today to speak on HB 1164 this is a bill
dealing with criminal record checks of
teachers credentialing applicants and
primarily it's been a uh a request of
the the Department of Education Mr
Applebee who is in charge of that
program over there and one of the issues
which we have is that upon entering the
education
program on a highered pro uh School such
as Plymouth or Keen or
UNH one declares for example I'm going
to be an education major an education
major then has to get that credentialing
criminal background check right from the
beginning they do it in their freshman
year that initial check is only good for
three years so in the fourth year when
they go out to do their student teaching
they have to pay to have that done again
the recommendation is the initial
credential be extended from 3 years to
four years thus saving money on the part
of a a student who's wanting to be a
teacher and that concludes my
testimony that's all the build us change
one number from three to four now thank
you representative any questions
uh represent Lakers do you know how much
it costs for them to get a peral records
check at this point I I can't tell you
that you know I've heard a lot of
different figures but I tell you with
the my grandkids are in college right
now $5 is a lot of money oh I know I
just was wondering what it was at the
moment thank you but this is up in
double or triple
figures yeah representer yeah I think on
that I think we heard that it was like
$150 I heard 15 2 but there's two of us
to say that now and I
agree
uh represent of
Woodcock thank
you
the I don't problem if if I uh extend
this to four years so I go out during my
student teaching um and to the school
and then I
graduate when I go to school X again at
the start all over again so wouldn't it
be um just as efficient if we started
the criminal record check in the higher
higher level of Education in the second
year because they had going on student
teaching they have do observations and
then it would carry over into the first
year of application for uh School
application to be teacher you see what I
mean I I understand that but of course
many of these gen head courses that are
taking as freshmen are also methods
courses in in education and if a
person's not going to pass that criminal
background check why then would they be
taking those courses so it's also a c
cost saving to have it as early as
possible but by extending it to to go
through that duration they have to get
another one check upon entering a school
uh of getting that credential so there's
a number of these checks which we heard
about in the teacher shortage committee
and that was one of the recommendations
that came out of the shortage committee
how to save students this this cost and
this is one recommendation that came out
of that that committee that we had this
summer okay thank you thank you
represent
Tanner thank you for taking it just
looking it up on the doe website it says
$25 that's not what we were told
criminal history record stuff yeah I I
think um there might be someone in the
back who has some information for us um
when we're when we're finished question
when we're finished grilling
representative
lad any more grilling of Representative
lad uh see none thank you very much and
is there someone um in the peanut
gallery who could help us
possibly thank
you down good thank you I'm Christine
Shay from New Hampshire State Police
criminal records unit I'm the
administrator and for student teachers
which are volunteers the record check
for us for a fingerprint base check is
2125 an employee would be
4825 for an employee and the first one
was
2125 yeah it's a fingerprint fingerprint
base check the 2 is a New Hampshire
check which is publicly available
records
check any
questions yeah could you repeat could
you repeat those numbers once again for
student and employee it is okay so for a
volunteer it's
2125 and for an employee a regular
teacher it would be
4825 thank you
represent McDonald thank you and thank
you for being here and answering that
question um another question what is the
difference um between the prices is that
a different check being performed
between student and employee no it's the
same check it's the we get a discount
from the FBI as well for a volunteer
because we get charged for them for
every check that we complete through
them so they recognize volunteers are
not getting paid for their service so
that's why there's a
difference represent Cornell Thank you
thank you for taking my question so this
is the national FBI check that check
correct it's only $25 no
$25 is the New Hampshire criminal
conviction check and that I think is
what representative Tanner was
referencing and the $25 check is just
publicly available New Hampshire
criminal conviction checks it is not
fingerprint based okay do you know how
much the other one is the the the
national either 2125 for a
volunteer or
4825 for an
employee thank
you both of the 2125 and the 4825 both
go through the FBI and it's fingerprint
based
okay you you mentioned um
21 maybe 25 for was it for non-
fingerprint also for just state
$21.25 right is for the volunteer right
and that's the FBI fingerprint check
correct right and
4825 for an employee fingerprint check
correct but was there another amount you
mentioned for um a state criminal
records check only right that's the $25
one but in this circumstance they need
to go with the fingerprint based
check any further questions
representative Woodcock I'm not going to
ask you how much you said it seven times
but it's okay the total so the total of
those who if I was a teaching applicant
it would be about 75 80 bucks they put
you put the fingerprint and the 40
together you wouldn't do both together
so when they were going through school
if it was you know just our piece of it
is just 2125 and then when they go to
get
employed then they would need to do the
4825 four years later if that makes
sense so for a to for a teacher
certification background check to go to
any school in Hampshire is still it's
not up the $125 $150 range it's not at
the figure you just hold us right I know
doe and I don't know if Diana might be
able to help answer some of this I know
doe has a different part regarding their
process so I'm not 100% sure what their
fees are when it comes to going through
the doe
process okay thank you you're
welcome thank you very much appreciate
your uh your answer on price she give us
a pink card could you ask her for a pink
card oh yes could you fill out a pink
card for us also thank you very
much um was there anything further from
the Department that um attorney Fenton
would like to add on to uh pricing
or anything for the the criminal records
checks question I just can't answer how
much it cost okay do does anyone have
any questions yes evidently someone has
a question for you we don't want you to
feel left out I don't want to feel up
that I hope you don't ask me how much it
costs cuz that was very I'll have to
defer my friend there represent Damon
thank you Mr chair I'm entirely asking
this question to not keep you left out
and it's not for the fee I got confused
with the last comment
so this is not the doe check but this is
for Teacher credentialing applicants I
don't understand the difference between
the doe check and whatever this
is so the the way that it's structured
if you look at I have the book thanks to
representative
Tanner um
she what's that do you have the blue
book I don't I don't have the new book
yet there's one on the there's one on
the table I'm I'm always behind so I'm
going to read old old L to you here
um thanks a lot representative Tanner I
didn't get my book this year it happen
check for the boss
I I should so if you look at
18913a and we'll start start with
18913a and then there's 18913 B and
C so looking at 18913 C talks about
credentialing and student candidates
credential and applicant and candidates
um so my understanding is that this
section was
created because if you have a teacher
prep program such as St anam's college
or Keen state which people are very
familiar with the issue became
that because those entities and I will
refer to my uh counterpart at the
department of safety who just testified
um if I could ask you to come join me
Christine um so my understanding and I
want to make sure that I'm saying this
correctly so I'll have uh I'll have my
counterpart here just in case I messed
up my understanding is Keen State SN
College they are non-governmental
entities they're private they're private
universities is that right correct okay
good so they're private and they cannot
receive the federal background check
right correct okay we're off to a great
start the Department of Education and
representative Damon I I see I want to
make sure I answer your question so if
uh if you want to chime in um so that
became an issue
because Keen state for example I'll just
pick on Keen State they couldn't access
this information and
so what ended up happening is if I'm a
candidate at a teacher prep program and
I wanted to go work at kennet high
school as part of my
academics I had to go to kennet high
school and kennet high school had to run
my record and Keen state was suddenly
left out of the
loop and Keen State and any college
wanted to be an active participant in
that discussion because they didn't want
to be having students who would not be
employable pursuant to the list of
disqualifying offenses found in
18913a real numeral
right they wanted to be an active
participant in that but because they
were not a non-governmental entity they
couldn't
be so it was left at the behest of each
individual school district and and
everyone knows I'm not from the field
but my understanding is in a teacher
prep program it is a fair statement that
as a teacher prep candidate you go to a
lot of schools you have a lot of
hands-on experience representative Cad
and I will just see if that's an
accurate statement and so it became a
huge burden on all these individual
schools Bartlett Elementary Berlin High
School what what have you to run these
multiple checks ta and the candidate was
having to pay out that money how much
2125 there you go
2125 every
time it's it's late it's 2 o'clock in
the afternoon we all needed a laugh
right so the candidate it became overly
burdensome not only on the schools that
were offering this great opportunity but
on the candidates
financially and logistically there were
problems because some candidates as some
college students they didn't have cars
right and they were having to go to the
troop station or the local police
department multiple times and and some
of the anecdotal evidence we were
hearing from students was that they felt
like they were being treated like
criminals having to go to the police
department multiple times they didn't
want to do it and frankly I don't blame
them no offense you guys are great but
um so these were some of the logistical
issues that were occurring the
department of education however is a
governmental entity and the department
can receive the criminal record check
from the FBI is that right that's
correct okay so far so good so that is
why 18913 C was created to alleviate
that burden from the field alleviate
that burden from the individual
candidate and the individual school
districts put it on the
department so the department could play
an active role in that because again the
department could get that piece of
information the FBI background
check that's why that section which was
passed by this legislative body was
created and now my understanding of the
bill in front of you is to expand the
time from a three-year period to a
4-year
period I hope that answers your
question
great anything further
uh representative Casen thank you can I
just add the criminal background check
is not transferable from one school
district to another that's
correct and I will add to that thank you
very much um you cannot disseminate that
record so one of the one of the
discussion points we have continually
had within this committee when questions
come up as to Department of Ed when you
are licensing someone to teach can't you
transfer that record to the employing
district the answer is a resounding no
is that right that's correct okay
perfect because you're not allowed to
disseminate the
record period end of sentence and so
that has caused issues at time as well
and I appreciate that comment because
again if I was a teacher prep candidate
and I went to Berlin high school for to
fulfill a requirement Berlin could then
they were not allowed to transfer that
record to kenet high school school which
is right down the road because it would
violate the federal regulations and
likewise kennet couldn't rely on well
they were just in Berlin they're fine
because it would be a stale
record great thank you very much um yes
representative Damon just want to verify
that you just said that the prohibition
on transferring or whatever the right
word was is federal
it's considered by it's considered by
the FBI to be a secondary
dissemination and they don't allow for
that the reason being is protecting an
individual's right to privacy and so
when they're signing off they're signing
off just for that individual
governmental agency to receive their
information great um yes represent T
quickly what did we do for bus drivers
and didn't we do something for bus
drivers that drive in different
districts um I maybe you can talk to um
uh Miss Fenton um offline because we
really want to focus on this bill and
want to have then a brief caucus I will
I can the short answer
is yes if you look at 18913 B I always
think of it as B for bus driver and C
for credential for candidate um but 189
13B was created to address the bus
driver issue to allow them
more Mobility pun
intended yes representative Cornell
Thank you thank you thank you for this
question because it's completely off the
wall but you have any idea why we're
like a number of us are coming up with
$150 hey don't I know um doe does have
some fees but I can't speak to what
their fees are specifically and I will
get you that information I don't know
off the top of my head um I don't think
for candidates it's a charge I know for
um when you be get certified as an an
educator all right I want to say $150
for three years but please don't quote
me on that I will get this committed
that information well thank you Mr chair
so I just
clarify for me I'm a student at Keen
state I'm a
sophomore and I'm declared that I'm
going to be a
teacher I run the I run the criminal
records check that goes through the
department this the the the department
hold
that records check which then enables me
to from keing state to go to manad high
school or conal high school because the
department holds the criminal records
check that I can use multiple sites to
do my student uh my student teaching
experience is that
correct that's my understanding and if
you look at 18913 C yes it talks about
the department completing that
confidential criminal history records
check then as a followup then as a once
I complete my uh program and I become
credentialed then the criminal record
check is specific to a school district
and the school district has that
criminal record check of which I can
only use that criminal record check for
that specific school district is that
correct that's when they become an
employee it's that is correct correct I
think it's a little bit more nuanced
than that simply because if you're if
once you're
licensed to become an
educator you're just licensed to be an
educator it's not for one particular
school that's not how the licensing is
structured but this bill is basically
dealing with the licensing
of for a student teacher correct not
let's don't get into my second question
let's just focus on this so This enables
a a student to be basically One records
check un during their undergraduate work
to enable them to have multiple teaching
experience student teaching experiences
is that correct that's the way the law
is already structured under 1893 just
moves it to another year that's right
thank you
we're done great
thinkk I tried sorry it's
quick thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um why are we not
doing it the same way for
teachers where where the department is
holding the background check so that
they
can they're not worrying about having to
do another check if they move to another
District
because you would remove the discretion
of each individual individual employing
school district and the way the system
is structured
currently is that the department just
reviews for what are called the
disqualifying offenses and again those
are found in
18913a paragraph five each school
district is allowed by law want to get
freshman involved consider other
offenses that are not on that list of
disqualifiers and that is by School
District policy they can take that into
account um and they can decide what is a
good fit in their particular school okay
thank you you're welcome great thank you
and um uh thank you for clarifying some
things for us and um you could further
help out by filling out a pink card Miss
Fenton I will do that um I I think um
representative Miler and his group is
going to go into the office for a couple
minutes for a caucus and we'll just a
caucus right here and you can stay where
all you
are
allad
e
uh thank you Mr chairman um this is
executive session for House Bill 1164
relative to criminal record checks for
Teacher cred eving
applicants
and uh do I hear a motion I'll make a
motion to approve 1164 and ask the
co-sponsor
okay any further discussion on the bill
no or the Motions no no great U Madame
clerk okay
for motion is ought to pass
representative cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative D yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
balbon yes representative cascaden yes
representative
Damon yes and chairman lad yes right 16
Y and for not
voting great consent calendar any
objections not hearing any objections
it's on consent that's will close the
executive session and get on with
business with the
hearings um looks like we're on 11 no
which one are we
1058 1058 correct relative to school
employee and designated School volunteer
criminal history records
checks
1058 looks like we got represent Perez
back here so this must be the prime
sponsor um yes welcome representative
thank you thank you Mr chairman and
thank you honorable members of the
Executive Education committee my name
again is representative Christine Perez
I'm from London Dairy uh Rockingham
district 16 I come before you once again
today with House Bill 1058 an act
relative to school employee designated
School volunteer his uh criminal checks
according to the Division of Youth and
Child families child abuse and neglect
are once again on the rise uh they took
a little dip during covid but they are
way up there again 60% of the report
that are brought in from schools and
daycares are screened in which means
that they go on for further assessment
assessment now there's only two other
reporters above that above the um
schools and daycares and that would be
um ones that were from the police or on
that were already involved with the
state um Court Affiliated and um has
hire as of February of 2019 19 40 States
classified failure to report a
misdemeanor if uh failure to report um
child abuse was a misdemeanor and if
convicted they could face jail time up
to 40 day 40 days to 5 years and fines
of $300 to 5,000 Connecticut right down
the highway uh can charge a a the
failure to report with a felony if it's
a subsequent
violation or if it is a willful VI
violation I remind you that we are
talking about children's law law
requires a any person who sus sub
suspects B abuse or neglect to report
but as certain occupations the report is
mandatory mandatory those professions
include but are not limited to
Physicians um priest nurse law
enforement teachers and school officials
again I repeat they are mandatory
reporters this bill applies only to the
school setting
um School setting professionals that are
mandatory reporters of child abuse and
neglect and are
required by DC to report to DCF or the
local law enforcement if they have
reason to suspect abuse or neglect the
three important words here are mandatory
required and suspect these School
individuals have training training on
what signs to watch for and how to
report these individuals are with
children 180 days a year and possibly
more hours in a day than parents
are abuse comes in many forms it's not
just the bruises you see or the broken
bones you see but it can uh be emotional
abuse that can cause extreme Behavior
changes withdrawal fear or acting
inappropriately the the school educator
is the perfect person to have the
opportunity to witness these changes and
it is their duty to protect the children
and report it you might ask why they
wouldn't report I have a few scenarios
what if I'm wrong my answer to that is
what if you're
right uh well that that Dad is my friend
while we're here talking about the
children um I know that family and
there's no way then I ask you if you
have a crystal ball or you know what
goes on behind closed doors this bill
would make failure to report a
disqualifying offense if the individual
charged is seeking employment or
credentialing this policy this is a
policy choice that we must consider and
ask ourselves if we want an individual
that has been charged Andor convicted of
failing to report child abuse or neglect
in our classrooms
thank you for your time thank you are
there any questions of the
representative yes representative
Tanner thank you um I'm kind
of uh a little bit confused I guess why
you would put failure to report abuse
and neglect as in violation of RSA 169
rather than just abuse and neglect is in
violation of because it's not that the
the School employee commits that it's if
they fail to report it but wouldn't you
not want to hire somebody that had
committed that well they would be if
they were charged with that that would
be a criminal offense so that would
probably fall under some of the other um
list of things that are not credentials
so so dangering the welfare of a child
oh yes sorry go ahead so um first degree
assault manslaughter oh not manslaughter
the first degree
assault so how how would somebody I I
just don't understand the failure to
report but we're as teachers we're we're
told that we are um you know obligated
to report abuse and neglect and um I
wouldn't want anybody hired that that
did abuse or neglect which I don't know
for sure if that's in one of these um
specified
uh specified uh criminal charges that
dis are immediately disqualifying and so
I guess how would failure to report
abuse or neglect be in um for example
criminal record checks would it be is it
is it something that people get charged
with is it something that happens a lot
I mean
it it does happen um failure to to
report does I mean it probably more
readily it would be from um people who
know the family and see this CH children
but I was speaking to someone here
earlier who said I have reported I
reported multiple times as a
teacher of things that have come up you
know children and but if you don't
report that is the criminal liability I
believe still here well I'll ask
somebody else yes I just how do you and
I believe that if you're convicted of
child abuse that would fall under
um uh I don't know if abuse and
neglect are under there
butet Park Street I don't want to go
there
going
next so I just don't know how the
failure you know how you get convicted
of failing to to and whether that
becomes apart is a criminal charge
that's at the level that these other
ones are so I guess that's my question
but Diana may have a little bit more
information on it can we borrow Diana
represent press yes and and I'll ask
this question because maybe she can
answer this one as well um abuse and
neglect and this law reporting to HHS is
pretty much in every state as a as a
teacher you must report if you suspect
mandatory mandatory no question no
question um so in the state of New
Hampshire do we know of the number of uh
schools that are reporting this did we
get some kind of an aggregated you know
result of this I do not have that how do
we know then and that's probably
directed right over to
your uh partner from doe here that do
how does doe know that maybe there's
some that are not reported does it come
as a result of a courtroom or HHS
reporting back to us and
saying there was an issue and we didn't
get through why I that would be my guess
is that the child is found to have been
abused or neglected and the child was
perhaps in the school and they at that
point might go back and say you know
didn't you notice that this child had a
broken arm one day and bruises the next
day
that type of thing that would be you
know a scenario that I could see I don't
think I think people are very hesitant
to report
unfortunately I think we forget that
it's the child we're dealing with and
not anything else other than the child
that were but because you are a teacher
and I was a
nurse you are a mandatory reporter so
only you only have to suspect it you
don't have to prove it you just have to
suspect it and my feeling is is maybe it
won't come out you know that this
happens a lot but I certainly wouldn't
want someone who didn't report it and
was found that they had not reported it
to be in a classroom be able to be
credentialed and be in a classroom and
the only way I could see that they could
actually
be um convicted of this is if it was
blatant if it was blatant and you know
or if it was unwilling they unwillingly
didn't do it there were several things
in um the Conneticut um information that
I had
um failing result can result uh this is
um the office of legislation from
Connecticut failing to report can result
in criminal penalties and expose the
mandated reporter to criminal damages if
the if the child is further injured
because of a mandated reporter did not
act um in February uh of 2019 40 States
classified failure to report as a
misdemeanor or similar
charges so failing to report is a crime
it's a crime so it's a crime against
children and that's who are in the
schools and that's who we want with
people who would report it if they only
only have to suspect they are
required does that answer your
question it's this a huge issue and as a
past
principal I had students living in my
district that have been kicked out of
their house in the backseat of a car and
the weather was colder than it was this
morning right - 10 - 15 is that neglect
yes is is it abuse yes yes and so the
reporting we did though we had many Ste
teachers in building this did not feel
comfortable on the phone with HHS it's
that's what it was called up there so we
had a process you went to the school
psychologist or the nurse the nurse was
a person with a master's degree in
nursing I was fortunate she made all the
contacts because we got through to the
people we need to at
HHS and we got immediate reaction we
reported but it wasn't necessarily
teacher Miler here it was teacher Miler
talking with the nurse and the nurse did
the reporting I don't know if that's
kosher or you know allow or not but
that's how we found it worked and I
understand that's how it could work but
technically it's technically technically
it's the person who knows of the abuse
is the primary a reporter you know as
far as I'm concerned as long as it gets
promot
immediately reported um what was the
delay on doing that was it done the same
day did it take three days of going back
and forth I mean we are talking about
children and we go out of our way to say
how and teachers especially go out of
their way about saying about how we have
to protect children and this is a way of
protecting children we do not want
people
who are uncomfortable has nothing to do
with it it's your job it's your
mandatory it's law you have to report
you have to report if you even
suspect and you know if people
understand that it might affect them in
a different way perhaps they'd be more
likely to do
it yeah represent Woodcock ch good
afternoon thank you I'm I'm I'm confused
which is apparently today the rule
um I'm reading this as a candidate for a
teaching position under this statute
where the superintendent or the director
or that organization is does not or
shall not hire but when you're talking
about theil to report that person is not
a teacher yet so they're not a mandated
reporter yet so I'm not sure how this
would be applicable that's my confusion
well I believe it says um
um or
volunteer wait a minute I can't find my
bill hang
on this would
be here we
go employer volunte that's the category
person but e in either case they
wouldn't they wouldn't have been hired
so it wouldn't have been the failure
report would just be like John citizen
at that point you're out of here now so
they wouldn't I don't understand
applicable to the to this particular
stat I understand what you're saying and
and and the importance of reporting I'm
just not understanding how I'm not an
employee yet so how can you ding me for
not being I'm not an employee if I I've
never reported it because I haven't I
haven't been a
reporter have you been charged with it
or have you this say failure report of
you doesn't say have B charges you a
failure
report that's all I'm just trying um but
that's my No that's
because someone who is um applying for
credentialing there's a whole list of
things that they can't and failure to
report would be added to this as one of
the credential in but they would have to
be they would have to be have been
convicted just like all these other
things they would have had to have been
convicted
of
So yeah thank you so let me say this so
this is you're just adding this to the
category of the listings of items so
wouldn't have been they have been found
guilty of fair report if you've been
charged and not found
guilty is that what you're saying yes
because I believe and I I leave this to
Diana but I believe if you've been
charged with capital murder and haven't
been convicted yet you still can't be
credential I'm not murdering anybody
it's fair
okay I'm just using one of the one the
top one well that one's a little bit
bigger um I I understand that okay I
just I just indecent and and indecent
and L exposure and less is a misdemeanor
MH if you have been
charged you can't have your credential
in is that
correct okay represent do you have a
question yeah just um representative
Perez um in the first section School
employee the employment section where
you're looking to hire someone um this
would not have to be a new teacher right
it could be someone who is a teacher
coming from elsewhere in the state or uh
somewhere else um in the area applying
for a job correct correct absolutely
thank you further
questions yes representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
bringing this forward um my question is
do and you may not have this information
that's fine but do you happen to have
any statistics for what percentage of um
of mandatory reported cases by teachers
in the state um result in any either
criminal or civil action being taken by
the state I don't I have the that 60% of
the cases that are brought forward from
school district schools or Child Care
60% of those are moved on for further
investigation there's two two ways they
can be moved in or moved out so 40% are
not moved on for for further
investigation but 60% of the ones that
come from schools or child care centers
are moved out for further investigation
thank you further
questions thank you very much thank you
do we have any other pink cards in this
um I I think
um Miss Fenton was bring up some
information I don't have one up
[Music]
here9
next are are you got a card in here for
technical support or come on
up are there questions for attorney
Fenton represent Tanner thank you first
of all uh I have a couple of questions
first question is out of the
21 criminal charges that are listed as
disqualifying is just abuse and neglect
one of
them no I do not believe that it is it
isn't okay and in your estimation how
many teachers in the state of New
Hampshire since you've been on the job
have been convicted of
failure to
report I I do know of one
instance uh that an educator was
convicted of
uh RSA 169 c29 failure to report I know
of one instance yes one one thank
you yes uh represent Paul thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question uh what if the kid comes in
with a broken arm couple weeks later
broken leg and what if I really don't
suspect anything I should suspect
something but I
don't is there anything that's going to
come back on me I mean how can you prove
how can you prove if somebody knew if
they suspected it how was that
proven well thank you for the question I
think it's a very nuanced complicated
question I will refer back to the the
case that I'm familiar with that I
referenced in my previous testimony to
representative Tanner in that instance
and it's just one example in that
instance the criminal conviction came
around came about because and and I
don't remember all the facts off the top
of my head it's been number of years now
but my understanding is the educator was
told by this child
that the adult in his life stepfather or
uncle whatever the case may be was
forcing him to perform sexual acts and
the teacher did not report that and that
is why the the criminal case was then
brought forward um and was successful I
I do think in very general terms it's
difficult to say well you should have
known right when you're just being
presented with a broken arm or a broken
leg what have you
um this law is really a policy choice
for this
committee what this Bill is saying is if
the
department and if the department has a
candidate come before it asking to be
licensed as an
educator and that individual has a uh
criminal record that that says this
offense of failure to report abuse and
neglect the policy choice for this
committee is simply should the
department issue that license or not
because the department does not have the
discretion individual school districts
have the discretion individual school
districts can look at that record and
say we're not comfortable hiring this
individual who failed who was convicted
of failure to report abuse and neglect
to be in our school district the
department by Design by this legislative
body does not have that discretion the
department when someone comes to be
licensed to to be an
educator we pull the
record sent to us from the Department of
Safety we review it and we look at the
disqualifying offenses and it is only
those disqualifying
offenses so if someone has DWI we will
still license that individual to teach
if that person has a theft case we will
license that individual to to teach it's
the disqualifiers that guide us so again
the policy issue for this committee is
to
say if someone from the state of Maine
or a new teaching applicant comes
forward to be licensed because we do not
continue to check the record um on a
reoccurring basis it's a one-time check
so if I move here and I apply for a New
Hampshire teaching credential and I have
failure to report abuse and neglect
and the department licensed that person
to
teach is that offensive to this
legislative body and that is truly a
question that's the policy question
contained within this bill and the
department is just seeking that guidance
because right
now that individual would would be
licensed further questions represent
Miley thank you Mr chair let me see if I
can get this clarified first of all I
don't think anybody in this committee
would want somebody who hasn't
appropriately reported and abuse Etc
understood but the the issue for me then
is that uh just a procedural question if
as a teacher I think there's some abuse
I then report that to the principal
correct that's that's that's the line
chain of command that I go to
first I would assume so that's going to
be a district policy okay so now now
this is this is the where I'm a little
unsure um teachers are under a heck of a
lot of pressure right
now I agree and and you've got the whole
issue of parental rights
Etc and so there my concern is is that
with with the en with the with the
environment that we're under right
now a lot of teachers are afraid
frankly and so if I see a child who
doesn't come to me in your in your
example clearly that was that was a true
absolutely but if I see some a child
that comes in with a broken
arm and I'm not quite
sure whether that was because of a
physical abuse on the part of the
parent and I don't report
that I think I probably should but I
know the parents and I'm afraid what
they might do to me if I make that
report where does that fit into the
issue of the quote
failure to
report I appreciate the
question um I'm not
sure best how to answer it because I
think from the Department's
perspective the department does doesn't
play a role in determining whether or
not that should be charged or or not
that would be a different a different
segment that would be the the
prosecution role a criminal role right
Police Department role um the department
is just left with reviewing the record
when that person applies to be a teacher
and then again is is governed by those
disqualifying offenses
and the question becomes I mean again
right now this is not an offense that
would prohibit the licensing of that
individual and so it really just becomes
a question of what the department does
with that yeah and I I clearly I can
appreciate the Department's position but
you can understand my concern in the
instance that I have sure um and and so
it's there is a lot of to my to my mind
clearly they ought to be reported
but you get into that question it's a
qualification question and I I would
assume that there's some ought to be
some concern about this fear of
reporting what that might mean to my
career to the child to whatever so
that's just that that's going around in
my mind as far as being a real real
quandry at this point in time thank you
and I agree with everything you you
stated I agree with everything you
stated the Department's position
is kind of the Department's the the last
you the Caboose on the train if you will
those policy decisions are made by other
agencies and entities and so the
department is really left with and and I
will refer back to your first comment
that we can all agree that it's a child
safety issue and we all want children to
be safe that's that's not the issue but
the department is in the
position that if an individual were to
come forward forward asking for to be
licensed and this offense is on the
record right now that individual would
would be licensed and that is the
quandry that the department finds itself
in and this legislative body would give
that guidance um and so unfortunately
the department For Better or For Worse
doesn't play a role in determining
whether charges should be brought if the
evidence is
sufficient we're not part of that
analysis thank
you represent T thank you is this a
department
request this is a bill that I have
discussed I believe I discussed with
representative Damon at one point um and
also representative perz it was I I
don't know if it's a department request
but I have spoken with both of those
individuals about this Bill yes follow
up on that yes so are we just going to
go through and add to this 21 um number
list of disqualifying ones because it
seems to me if we've had one incidence
of this and and how many years have you
been with the
Department approximately uh a little
over eight years I believe yeah okay and
100 I don't know how many schools and
how many kids that does it rise to the
level of total disqualification that you
can't get you your professional
certificate or can't get a credential I
mean does it that's that's the issue
it's not abuse and neglect if you get
charged with abuse and neglect you're
not on that top of the list but if um
and and you know there there are some
other ones that we could be a lot more
picky but when we got those 21 you know
we really went for something that was
was
happening a lot not just once in8 years
or maybe whatever so I I just I don't
know where this is coming from I feel
like it's a gotcha for for people going
into the teaching field and I think Bill
Bill see it as that
too yes represent Hall thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
so I'm wondering on line
22 um when it does say any person who
has been
charged not convicted I guess I'm
thinking myself innocent until proven
guilty so you're not going to credential
me someone has charged me yet I can't
get credentialed is is that the intent
here so the thank you for pointing out
that language so so that language any
person who has been charged pending
disposition that phrase is already
currently in the law that phrase has
consistently been in the law and that
phrase is I think a simplistic way of
saying charged which means there was
probable cause and is awaiting
trial and so for purposes of credential
um you're right that presumption of
innocence is applicable in the the
criminal context for administrative
credentialing
purposes that has always been in uh
18913a and then in the subsequent
sections that we've talked
about Diana the there's some
subjectivity to this whole federal law
when they enter in the word
suspect a child falls down the stairs
and breaks a leg or gets all bruised up
and it wasn't the result of a parent and
the teacher in the classroom absolutely
knows this
family I don't suspect anything there I
know them and so but what happens later
that you know the child is found to be
you know um you know a result of abuse
and neglect but how where's the teacher
stand on that who you know because it's
suspect and that teacher had every right
to say what that teacher was you know
thinking and
believing I wouldn't say they would be
guilty but you know you're the
prosecutor where are you coming from
this angle well and thank you for the
question to to be very clear um I was a
criminal prosecutor years ago and so I
have that work experience but that's not
my current current job and and uh you
for one are always giving me new job
titles so you keep me on my toes um but
I think your question really hearkens
back to representative Myer's
question which is there's a lot of
various circumstances and and nuances in
this area and to be very Frank it can be
a scary area yeah it is um and as I
mentioned in my answer to representative
Miler the department is not in a
position
we are not an active participant in
those charging decisions we are not an
active participant in the criminal piece
of it I just happen to have that
background just as each and every one of
us has our own respective backgrounds
that we bring with us um the
Department's position is narrowly
tailored and the Department's position
is simply reviewing an individual
applicant's criminal history upon lure
and that is an act that was passed by
this legislative body to give the
department that
role to review the disqualifying
offenses the department again does not
have any
discretion no discretion whatsoever the
department is limited to these offenses
that are that are enumerated in the
statute and if an individual were to
have this particular offense a failure
to report abuse or neglect the question
you again right now the department would
license that individual and that
individual would be available to to work
in an educational setting school
districts have discretion and school
districts could exclude that individual
based on that
offense that's the role the very limited
role the department would play thank you
just again just to kind of summon my own
mind sure with you
you're not involved in the issue of
whether or not there was a failure to
report you B that's done in another
venue that's done in another Court
that's done in another process yes yes
or no whether or not that individual did
it if in fact they neglected to do that
reporting that's a decision over here
when you go to do your check if this
happens over here here you have nothing
to do with they we here all you're doing
is reviewing did this happen that's the
Department's role right what this what
this bill is basically saying that if in
some other
jurisdictional issue found that somebody
failed to reported all you're doing is
saying okay it happened over here we
can't provide that then that is correct
pardon me you're not getting your
credential you're not you're not going
to get your credential because something
happened over here that the department
wasn't involved in all you're doing is
receiving the report of that action of
another venue you are correct thank
you represent whitcock thank you
chairman you're welcome I just to follow
up if if um this
passes and a current employee is found
failing to report do they lose their
certification or are they released from
the school district
District the license your rather if a
current employee were to be charged with
this offense of failure to report it's a
law right yes uh yes that would be
reported to the department and if it's
one of the disqualifiers the department
could could take action on that yes yes
thank you thank you are there any more
question yes representative
cordelli um am I correct with any of the
items listed in section five the
Department's is just to look and see if
this group over here charged someone and
is either convicted or a pending trial
you have you know there's a wall here
and you're on this side of the wall is
that
correct yes I think so um I'm not sure
which side of the wall you were
referring to there but right but the way
I explain it is the department simply
doesn't have discretion
so there was an individual who came
forward to apply for a license and they
had been charged not convicted but
charged with first-degree murder the
department didn't have any discretion
did not license that individual that's
one of the disqualifying
offenses again there are a lot of
offenses that are not on this list that
the department will license does license
and it is the school district that has
more discretion so if this if it is on
this
list and it appears on a record the
department can not license that
individual are there further questions
representa
Damon thank you um
so if the individual charged with one of
the current offenses or this if it
passes into law were charged and
therefore did not get their credential
and then were found
innocent they would then be able to
request their teaching certification yes
no I I believe that is correct I'd like
to break that down a little bit so if I
apply for a license and I have been
charged with this offense currently I
would be
denied if I was then found not guilty
and I apply
again my understanding of the the law is
currently written in this bill then yes
I would be
licensed oh
yes so if someone is found innocent is
the fact that they were
charged retained on their record At Doe
or somewhere else or is it purged
because they've been found
innocent
so that's a really good Department of
Safety question I want I want to be
clear the department pursuant to the law
and I'm just trying to put my hands on
it really quickly the department has an
obligation to destroy the criminal
history record after a certain amount of
time so the department does not keep and
compile these records these records are
housed with the Department of Safety
they are not housed at the Department of
Education and the department doesn't
keep them we don't keep records of them
we just make that decision based upon
that list of disqualifying offenses that
we've talked
about in terms of what is retained on
the
record I will refer to my my counterpart
of the Department of
Safety welcome back thank
you so when we get the Court's
dispositions over which is is whatever
the finding is from the court it could
be n pross non-conviction
all various um
dispositions that will be on the record
but when education is entitled to a full
record which means they see convictions
and non-conviction as well so it would
still be there but it would show that
they were not convicted of that charge
oh yes go
ahead please tell me if I'm
understanding you correctly or fix my
understanding so if a person were
charged with failure to
report and then the court proceeding
found that that was not
valid that record that they were charged
would be retained at Department of
Safety and if they then made a
subsequent application for their
teaching
license the fact that they had been
charged would be reported to the
department it would but it would also
show that it was a non-conviction
on that so also something to keep in
mind is people are entitled to anull
their records so they can go to the
courts and get any charges taken off
from their record their various rules
and parameters with that but that is
something that they can do in which case
that would not show
up but generally speaking it would show
up as a non-conviction
however if they were going for let's say
their nursing license nursing is not
entitled to a full record record so they
see convictions only in which in that
circumstance that would not show
up thank you for
explaining why is it not
purged I would have to research that
further that has just been traditionally
pay grade level yes what we have to do
is that
is the process with dispositions from
courts further questions from the
committee I may add something to that
answer
um this legislative body changed the
law
probably this per for me more than five
years ago to allow the release of the
entire
record um
previously the the entire record was not
released actually there's quite a bit of
History to it so more than 10 years
ago when a school district submit um
wanted to hire someone they would submit
the criminal records request to the
Department of Safety it was the
department of safety someone such as
this person right here my good friend
who would read through the applicant's
record and they would read through the
person's record and then they would
write a letter to sa39 or sa9 and say
dear superintendent this person does
have a disqualifying offense and cannot
be hired or this person does not have a
disqualifying offense and they can be
hired they would write a a letter and
the superintendent would never see the
individual applicants criminal
record however what ended up happening
was there was a gentleman in uh the
western part of the state in Sullivan
County who was charged with
um Colonius aggravated sexual assault
ifsa something of that
nature and for whatever reason those
charges were reduced down to misdemeanor
offenses and that individual applied to
a school district that individual's
hired and that individual
reoffended it was based on that instance
that this legislative body then amended
the law to allow the release of um
felonies I think it was all
felonies and then it became included
misdemeanors and then it included the
entire record I'm not sure if it was
broken down in those exact Parts but it
was legislative changes over time and if
you look at the history of this
law
18913a you will
see that there's been an enormous number
of amendments in the last in the last
decade um because of some of those ISS
issues that were brought forward to this
legislative body and I know
representative Tanner has done a lot of
work on this particular area because it
is a very complicated
area yep it is any other further
questions thank you
both oh there is one representative Hall
you did call on me earlier but then we
got but thank you for thank you CH thank
you for taking my question so you I'm
just going to circle back to um
representative Woodcock when he asked
you about if you currently have
certification and your answer I think it
was that the doe could take
action you know it's so that you could
revoke my credentialing is that like
black and white you know the could um no
my my understanding is superintendant
have an obligation to report if someone
is arrested for a disqualifying offense
currently working with the school
district disqualifying offense they are
obligated to report that
yes um in such an instance the
department could take an immediate
suspension of that individual's
credential um and and then see what how
the criminal process plays out
yes
and
yep who who decides what part who decid
so let's say I've been charged and the
department
whoever the department is I mean I know
you're the department I mean you're we
work for the department but decides that
we should take her credentialing away
and I've been charged I've not been
convicted would that never happen or
that might happen no that that very well
could happen it has happened if an
individual is arrested um and we have
had this situation happen I don't want
to say a multiple instances but we have
had this happen and you'll it's
typically reported in the news if an IND
licensed educator is uh arrested
for kidnapping or possession of child
pornography or sexual
assault the department can and has and
and does it is discretionary but can
um take action on that individual's
license the theory being if that person
cannot be employed in a
district they they shouldn't have the
license either so the license is
immediately suspended the department has
done
that previously the criminal justice
system then does what the criminal
justice system does the department has
no role in that I will refer back to
representative Myer's testimony I
thought he explained that very well it's
done in a different forum and the
department doesn't play any role in that
particular forum and then the department
is there will respond accordingly based
on what happens over here the department
is more
reactive doesn't play an active role in
it but if a teacher is arrested the
department will then respond accordingly
yes I just follow up just real quick I
think I was I in my mind I'm thinking
more of this failure to report abuse not
murder child abuse all that so I was
thinking from that point of view but
thank you but if this law were to pass
then that offense is listed amongst with
all those offenses right now if the
offense of failure to report it's not a
disqualifying offense so the department
would not take that action right thank
you any further questions don't see any
more questions but for both of you I
represent somebody
Tanner who usually reports failure to
report who usually puts the crime
forward like who charges you know like
is it app parent if the kid comes to
school and and something happens and the
kid says oh I'm going to get killed if I
go home and he gets killed and I haven't
reported it who who who files a report
against me who who files a
charge
typically the charges are brought by the
police department yeah whatever local
police department the department How
would how would they know that the kid
had said that to
me that goes beyond the the role of my
position I each CA case is individual
but any charging decisions are brought
by the local police department yeah the
Department of Education has no role in
that yeah any further
questions I did have a call from
director applebe over there at the
department the cost for initial
certification for student is $1 140 plus
doar the $100 is Administrative costs
for the that are set by the department
and your costs are exactly what you said
$40 something dollars for the safety
aspect of it so when we're talking that
150 you're on base represent Cornell and
represent mil so thank you both for
coming and your reward for all that do
you want a
book the new
one you're welcome to have it because I
have
two I appreciate it I'm sure got that
one I'm sure there's wait one waiting
for me thank you though yeah thank you
very much and with that there's no more
cards on this one so we're going to
close this
hearing
me she goes first the prime SP who's the
Prime sponsor of the bill yeah so she's
the one that goes first
okay yeah Rosemary's right here no no no
Val I thought we had one that's what
she's looking for oh Valerie Val it's
right here second one oh
yeah okay with that we're going to go
ahead and open up our last hearing for
today it's HB
1109 and relative to re iring student
identification cards to include the help
line for the National Alliance for
eating disorders and I'd like to invite
representative rung the prime sponsor to
present the
Bill thank you very much Mr chair and to
the education committee for the record
my name is Rosemary rang and I represent
Hillsboro 12 which is the town of
miramac and for some reason I'm getting
such a strong sense of deja vu because
we were here a year ago
um to make the case for the need to
include an eating disorders helpline on
the back of student IDs and I think we
made a pretty good case for what the
situation is with our young people and
the need to provide as much information
and and help line to them and to their
families and friends um and and I'm glad
that the committee agreed and recommend
it ought to pass as amended um and I'm
very grateful that the house also passed
it and the Senate education committee
passed it and the Senate passed it but
around that time and I and I do want to
thank representative cordelli and some
other Representatives who brought to my
attention around the same time there was
a lot of mismanagement going on with the
organization that provided the helpline
at the time it was the national Eating
Disorders
Association and um within a few weeks
they had disconnected their helpline
they had
instituted uh some type of a remote I
forget the name of it it's like a bot to
to accept questions it was just a really
a total failure in management and I
believe that that director um lost her
job over it um so um on the advice of
myself and other people Governor sonunu
rightly vetoed
hb35 but that didn't make the problem go
away did it there are still many young
people who are suffering even dying from
eating
disorders um and and you'll hear
probably more information on that but
what I I wanted to talk to you about is
that after um The veto and I was unaware
of how much attention that bill got
outside of New Hampshire but um one of
the the the drivers of that bill Mr
Matthew Brown received uh was contacted
by an association called the National
Alliance for eating disorders and they
felt that providing that helpline was
really important and they want wanted us
to consider new legislation that their
helpl line could be added to the back of
the ID and I certainly did not want to
get in the position of partnering with
an organization to find out a few months
later their mismanagement was really
going to torpedo the intent of of the
legislation so I had um corresponded
with them several times we had a zoom
meeting with their executive director
and I can wholeheartedly say I have
complete trust and faith in the ability
of the National Alliance for eating
disorders to be able to provide a helpl
line um they have a history of s of
success in um enabling people who have
any disorders to be able to access
therapy um they have real people on the
other end of the phone line therapist
trained I think they use some trained
volunteers
um they have very um convenient hours
that they're expecting to expand and I
believe you may have gotten
correspondence from their executive
director um so if if you haven't let me
know I'll try to get that for you so I
come to you again asking for an autopass
recommendation on HB
1109 it is in essence the exact same
bill that this committee approved as
amended um except that we we are with a
more solid organization who can provide
that service and I would be happy to
take any questions thank you very much
other questions from the
committee yes represent
Ry thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um the social service are uh
organizations in my area spent a lot of
time and money in N
2022 um expanding the 988 number from
just a suicide hotline to a mental
health and crisis hotline um it's
available
247 and the uh rationale behind that was
because a three-digit number 988 was a
lot um lot easier to remember than a
10-digit number and so the thrust in
emergency medicine um has been to co uh
you just to um condense these all into
the 988 uh triaged hotline number um why
do you think this would be uh a time to
go against that Trend oh U
representative I thank thank you very Dr
thank you very much for that question I
think it's an extremely important
question um because all of us should
have that on our minds
but we are not a sixth grader or a 10th
grader or a high schooler we are adults
and the the target audience for the
intent of this bill are youth they're
adolescents they're teenagers and they
don't think they have a mental illness
they would not look at that crisis line
and think that that's a place where they
can get help or have their questions
answered they but if they see eating
disorders and that's the key they need
to they can see themselves as having an
eating disorder or maybe just I'm not
eating like my friends do my parents are
always on my back that I'm not I'm
losing weight
they would I can't even imagine and I'm
looking back really at my three kids
when they were that age I don't think
they would have ever thought or
identified as someone who had a
potential mental disorder but they
definitely would say I have an eating
disorder I'm not eating normally so it's
really um we need to communicate to the
the target group in a way that they can
relate to and if if I believed and if if
Educators and people that are experts in
pedagogy um would think that a sixth or
seventh or eighth grader would be able
to say oh I have a mental disorder um I
may be at risk for suicide because of it
I better call this this 988 number I
would be all for that but I I think we
would be missing a lot of people who
need this number because they just don't
identify with that
yes thank you
um the 988 number is advertised as uh
suicide and crisis hotline and in fact
if you go to the National um Alliance
for eating disorders it says after the
this their time it says if you have a
crisis call 988 so I'm wondering why put
in that extra step they're sending them
there um if they're not available and
that's a long time that's not weekends
and they're not on evenings or weekends
why not just put 9
and8 again an excellent question but I
think what the intent of this bill is is
to reach people who children who are
suffering from an eating disorder reach
them early before it becomes a crisis or
before they become suicidal we do know
that so many people who suffer from
eating disorders end up in a crisis they
end up in um a suicide ideation but when
they're younger when they're in those
early teenage years they don't they're
not there yet so they still would not
relate to that they um they're going to
call when they realize geez my friends
are saying things to me my families are
saying things to me about my eating oh
there's this eating disorder help line I
think I'll give them a call it's a
different situation than if if they said
oh suicide crisis hotline that I'm not
there I'm not I'm not thinking about
suicide I'm not in a crisis I just you
know people think I have an eating
problem so I still don't think if if the
988 number said Eating Disorders you
know all the way to where you might have
suicide ideation or crisis I think it
would be worth revisiting but right now
people view their perception of 988 is
I'm in an emergency situation something
really bad's going to happen unless I
call this number but the the people the
children we want to reach aren't nearly
there yet but they will get there
without a hel
line further question represent
beler thank you Mr chair and uh thank
you for this bill and my question is
going to be because you just brought up
an interesting point that really sparked
something for me
so the suggestion is how is a student
know that the the current existing
hotline is okay to call not just for
like an emerging crisis but for an
eating disorder or any of these other
things but clearly the line as as we've
seen because we've been through this
before that line is designed to be able
to triage and send people to the kind of
care that is necessary including
non-emergent including things like
eating disorders so would it not make
sense to instead of putting another
number on the card that and just you
know giv giv just start the students the
card and and not saying a word about it
just it's just there maybe they see it
maybe they don't maybe require ing a 5
minute instruction on the scope of the
current number and that you can call
this for eating disorders or anything
else that you need
to um I thank you very much repres for
the question I hope I'm understanding it
correctly um I think educating an eighth
grader seventh we know what they're like
um educating them giving them a f minute
educational talk about the application
of 98
um I'm not sure that would take as much
as they would recognize Eating Disorders
that's for me and another important
point I I haven't really made yet is
that the people on the other line of
this helpl line are highly trained in
Eating Disorders it is a very specific
disorder um it's not something you can
lump in with other medical issue uh
mental issues I think we heard testimony
on that when this bill was brought up
last year but it is very specific so it
actually saves a step um by calling this
number directly they can they can hear
from therapists and and people who know
exactly what type of situation they're
in and what help they need and and
because this organization is one that a
988 might refer someone to so we're
actually saving a step for Youth and
having them call this number directly I
hope that answered your question
it does and if I may have a brief
followup because you brought up the the
concept that that this young child might
understand properly that they already
have an eating disorder so it's in their
mind that they are sort of self-
diagnosing eating disorder so I'm going
to direct myself to the number on the
card that says eating disorder but what
if they don't realize that what they're
dealing with is an is exactly an eating
disorder would it not make more sense to
call a more generalized line and that
way they can be sort of diagnosed and
and and moved down that track um I guess
so I think this number would appeal to
to youth that recognize that something's
different about their eating I mean
eating eating is something we do about
three times a day if you don't snack um
and so when we're not eating consistent
with what other our family our parents
expectations are what our friends expect
us are the focus is on the eating part
so I think they would relate more to a
help line that talked about eating
disorders and and I would I
mean I I agree with you in a way that a
child may call this number not thinking
they have an eating disorder that just
they got issues with their eating I
don't know if they'd even put the word
disorder on it but I think if they saw
eating disorder they would they would
recognize that oh this is for people who
are not meeting eating expectations of
their family or maybe they realize that
Jesus um something's a matter if I have
to run to the bathroom after eating to
expel what I just ate you know they're
going to recognize that that is a
disorder so I hope I answered your
question thank you f question
representative
Tanner thank you and thank you for
taking my question this hotline um is it
just for the people in crisis or is it
for the kids that are friends and say G
my friend has an eating disorder you
know what can I do um oh there's a
seating disorder number I can I can call
is it is it is it not just crisis is it
for other kids that are working with
peer counseling on a informal basis it's
for anyone that has a concern about an
eating disorder so a parent might call
might see it on their child's ID and
said because we know that that happens
we know that I know at the suicide
hotline parents are ones that call that
often because of their concerns about
their child so um no this this runs the
gamut representative Tanner from people
who have a concern about a loved one um
to someone who really feels that they
need they need some medical help or they
need some therapeutic help so it it runs
a gamut and but depending on what that
issue is the nature of that call they
may be referred to someone else they may
be referred even referred to 911 um or 9
988 or or a hospital it really
depends further
questions representative uh on line 14
of the
bill uh there under Roman three there's
an area where say
annually the information on the card
shall be certified with their
legislative body or I guess with the uh
not the respective governing bodies does
that mean there has to be some process
in which this is communicated with the
school board or what's the how do you do
this certifying um let me read it again
hold on ening my
glasses oh um with that with that and I
think that was in the original
legislation too um Mr chair it it just
means that they have to confirm that
that's the correct number if they are re
you know reissuing those student IDs at
the beginning of the year they just have
to confirm that the and and it's it
doesn't necessarily have to be with
their governing board it's the
administration of the school so if the
administration is going to be issuing
new student IDs um they would have to
confirm that the the number for the
National Alliance for eating disorders
is accurate and up to
date would it be better than uh question
that public schools Charter Public
School charter schools issuing student
at ification cards pursuant to this
section shall annually and prior to the
start of each year
certify that the student identification
you know without having to mention to
the administration that that the the
district the school is going to
certify um well when I I I think I'm I'm
interpreting the word certify as
confirm like yes we are going to put
this number this number will be on our
ID yeah is that your interpretation it
make sure everything is current right
correct yeah thank you uh further
questions from the
committee thank you very much thank you
very much representative
McDonald hello representative Valerie
mcdonal Rockingham
25 and I'm a co-sponsor of this bill and
I Echo the remarks that have been said
and I will leave some of the more
technical details for those who will
speak after me however just to remind
you last year hb35 passed this committee
with strong bipartisan support passed
the Full House pass the Senate education
committee and pass the full Senate I
simply ask that the committee views this
bill favorably once again I'd also like
to say thank you to Mr Matthew Brown who
is here and has brought this bill
forward which he is inspiring his peers
to get involved in the Civic process um
I will be happy to take any questions
but the primary reason that I have
decided to testify today is to present
my own student ID cards because some of
you have expressed interest in seeing
these in previous discussions um they're
dated 2020 and 2021 but to the best of
my knowledge these are the current
design specifically to the Salem School
District but across New Hampshire
schools have similar ideas cards in
respect to shape and size I figure the
committee May benefit from a tangible
example you can note that on the back is
the National Suicide Prevention Lifeline
that is already required by State
Statute the bill in front of us hb19
would add the National Alliance for
eating disorders heline um these
specific cards do contain additional
phone numbers that the Salem School
District opted to include but are not
required in State Statute so other
districts May incorporate their own
phone numbers as they see fit but thank
you thank you very much are there
questions for the representative
representative
dry thank you um and thank you for
taking my question and I understand this
is a serious issue and I'm certainly um
in favor of of students having access to
help that they need um I'm just
wondering uh why this one there are
other issues that affect uh grades 6 to
12 you know pregnancy human trafficking
domestic abuse alcohol all those things
do we want a long list or do we want
something that's going to be easy to
access thank you for the question from
my understanding the reason Eating
Disorders was selected is because of its
prevalence especially among adolescents
it is one of the largest contributors to
suicide rates within that age group
which is why I believe it was selected
because it is such a predominant issue
these days
especially further questions yes
represent Bel thank you Mr J I just
wanted to ask can you I don't need to
know what they are necessarily but can
you tell me how many phone numbers are
listed on that Salem ID Yes again this
is specific to Only Salem Salem has the
school's main office um they also have a
line labeled see something say something
which would connect a student with the
school resource officer and then a third
number which is the suicide prevention
Lifeline that I mentioned and that's
required by Statute AG thank you
represent whitcock thank you represent
thank you for being here
take speak um and
also I wonder particular on the
committee back to the committee
additional uh consideration might be
also the inclusion in the annual parent
student
handbook yeah I would definitely work
with the sponsors if they will be
interested in that but I could see that
as a valuable addition thank you're
welcome are there further questions
thank you very much thank you I'd like
to invite uh represent
Damon good afternoon committee thank you
chair for the record representative hope
Damon Sullivan District 8 I'll save you
listing the nine towns in Sullivan
County that I represent
um as noted this is a bit of deja
view um this is a
topic
so dear in my
heart I spent over 40 years as a
dietitian mostly in private practice and
about 50% of my patients were people
with eating
disorders they were the people I lost
sleepover they were the people that you
didn't know if it was going to come out
okay in the
end early diagnosis early intervention
early treatment with eating disorders is
strongly predictive of better
outcomes so the sooner that a young
person having symptoms of an eating
disorder is able to get input and help
the more likely that we save their life
I'm not being melodramatic anorexia is
the number one cause of death among
psychiatric
diagnosis it's very very serious it is
certainly not the only eating disorder
and they all have very significant
medical nutritional psychological life
impact so as noted we were very
successful with this bill last year
until due to circumstances beyond our
control we had the UNT forunate
circumstance of needing to ask it be
vetoed I am beyond 100% confident that
the National Alliance for eating
disorders is the organization we should
have aligned with to begin with and that
they will be here for us
indefinitely it was founded in
2000 last year they made
264,000 30% of those calls were from
people under
18 so that is an enormous body of
benefit the founder and CEO is Joanna
Kendell if you worked in Eating
Disorders you know Joanna as a person
who is revered for her own personal
recovery and then her Education and
Training and ability to train others and
to help people get well she's truly an
extraordinary person and she supervises
all of
this all of the people who answered this
helpline are licensed therapists and
Mental Health Counselors and they're
supervised by a
psychiatrist the Merit of that is not
only that they're licensed people but
that they specialize in Eating
Disorders one of the things that was
always fascinating to me in working to
help folks with eating disorders and you
almost always work in a team it's not
treated by a dietitian or a therapist
but by a collaborative of Professionals
of different
disciplines it was hard to find
therapists who were enthusiastic about
working with people with eating
disorders because it's complex it's
scary and I don't know why but it didn't
tend to be it's gotten better but it
didn't tend to be the discipline for
mental health
professionals to have passion for
and when a person who has an eating
disorder especially a young
person reaches out for help it is
critically important that the person
that they talk
to have very thorough credible
understanding of these conditions have
compassion no
judgment and quite frankly do not he in
what they
say because there are way too many
unfortunate Tales of people who ask for
help and one of the first responses they
got was really you look great you don't
look like you have a problem that is the
perfect validation that a person with an
eating disorder should stay eating
disordered it's not what we want people
to receive when they ask for
help so
um just to before I wrap up um note a
couple things the email that I think
representative rung mentioned from
Joanna Condell from the National
Alliance is in your inboxes from January
16th so two days ago please read it it's
really a good thoughtful explanation of
the
heline um and in response to I think it
was representative dr's question um
about other conditions and why this
particular one for this age group this
population there's more incidents of
eating dis in adolescence then there is
substance
abuse there is eating disorders
co-occurring commonly with depression
and anxiety and OCD as parallel
disorders parallel is probably not the
right word but
co-occurring um but in this age group
this is the time to help them get
Specialized Care that is specific to
their
situation and I would reiterate
representative Run's remarks most kids
with with eating disorders do not see
themselves as in a mental health crisis
as
suicidal they know they're troubled they
come to know that they're doing things
in a way that is harmful to
them but I don't think I could list a
single patient that I worked with who
would have called the 988 number they
just didn't categorize themselves in
that way and I hugely respect that we
have 988 and can concisely say
for the folks that that
fits and and Market that but this is not
the same as
that I'll stop there please vote this
OTP thank you very much representative
Damon are there any questions from the
committee yes represent
joh I I do appreciate very much what
you're doing um so my question is what
hours is this National hotline open
thank you I'm going to just reference
that that message because it's in
[Music]
there it is open Monday through Friday
9:00 a.m. to 7:00 p.m. they're expanding
their hours this year to be 9
to9 and then working towards weekend
hours um and I think there was a
statement bear with me just a
second because I think they referenced
988 in here somewhere it it says if you
have a crisis right underneath the hours
no I'm reading the hours in the text oh
anyway hopefully you all read it I won't
take your time hunting sure okay so my
point is that nights and E late evenings
and um weekends you're going to get a
number 988 that will triage you to
people who are equally trained because
they're going to send it to the right in
the right direction
so
I'm just wondering
how why why two numbers okay thank you
thank you for the
question I think we have a difference of
opinion about them being equally trained
because although they may have the same
credential say licensed clinical mental
health
counselor the people on the National
Alliance response line
specifically trained in eating disorders
and there is a difference in the way
people experiencing Eating
Disorders hear the
language
I if they just hear things in a through
a different filter than what a person
who doesn't have an eating disorder
would hear remarks
from a fair number of these calls and I
don't have data on this this is
my uh my
experience actually are during school
hours because when kids with eating
disorders are around their peers it is
both triggering and it is sometimes and
it is
also their peers are likely to help them
call for
help and I actually meant to say that I
think that is another benefit of putting
this on ID
cards that people who are not suffering
from the eating disorder will see that
there's a place to call for help
and they can call and find out how to
help their friend get help or a parent
or a sibling likewise I don't think they
should be perceived as competing numbers
they're both incredibly valuable numbers
for the population that needs
them thank you represent
beler thank you Mr chair and thanks for
your your technical expertise on this
matter would I be correct if I were to
say that or if I were to ask that um
Eating Disorders might incompass not
just disorders of undereating and
malnutrition but also
overeating you would be very correct in
fact compulsive overeating and binge
eating disorder occur at greater
frequency than restrictive Eating
Disorders thank you and if I may I'll
follow up on that because I'm I'm
looking and I haven't looked a lot
because I just brought it up but I'm
just looking at the website for The
Alliance for eating disorders and I've
gone to their blog and I'm looking at
some articles a few articles and there's
a consistent theme showing up um
against what they refer to as diet
culture and they they seem to be
suggesting that people should not
Embrace dieting and they seem to be
bordering on supporting the body
positivity
movement um and for those unfamiliar
body positivity is a is a movement that
suggests healthy any size doesn't matter
if you're obese you should embrace that
about yourself um and I'm wondering if
that's something that is known about
this organization and if that is indeed
what they're
promoting thank you for the
question
um it is
well
accepted in nutrition
Professionals
for I'm not always great about time
frames but I want to say the last 10
plus
years that our diet culture and what we
mean by that is the decades long
practice of prescribing some pattern of
eating that is supposed to make that
person become
healthy addressing whatever diet or
nutritional concern body concern they
had and what we found particularly in
regards to Weight Control weight
management and eating disorders is they
don't
work
so I would be very confident that any
person in this room in this building in
this town you get the point who has been
on a diet to change their body
size has probably had some success at
changing their body size as long as they
uh maintain the discipline for the diet
for a long enough period of time to get
some quote unquote
results and 97% of the time people stop
St the highly prescriptive structured
sometimes with buying particular
products but some particular dietary
pattern and when they stop it they
return to the body size they previously
were and over time usually a little bit
more
pounds and that cycle only it really
should be graphed not the way I just did
up and down more like stairs kind of
crooked stairs because essentially the
more you diet the fatter you become over
decades
so embracing non-diet culture is good
that isn't saying that we don't care or
don't
expect eating disorders professionals to
encourage a healthful pattern of
eating but it's not a
prescriptive here's your plan do this
don't eat these
Foods because it doesn't work the
science doesn't support it any anym I
could go on and on about that and I'm
sure you guys don't want me to but feel
free to bring that up um off the Record
thank you very much are there questions
further questions from the committee not
see any thank you very much thank you
represent
Howard
thank you Mr chairman and uh fellow
committee members uh my name is
representative Heath Howard I represent
the towns of straford and barington uh
HB 119 is something that's really
important to me as somebody who has a
loved one who has been affected by any
disorder uh this loved one they
developed the eating disorder in high
school and despite all of the support
that uh their mother was giving them and
uh all the help that uh they had they
still uh were worse off enough to end up
uh being put in the hospital and this
this line isn't just about those who are
suffering but it's about their families
as well because uh their mother they
they were really trying to educate
themselves about everything that they
were going through with
anorexia and it it's it it's tragic to
me to see that people could be going
through the same
thing providing this helpline is
providing specific directed
information that families friends can
reach out to and uh get get the
information that they need to help
whoever is
suffering and I mean when it when it
comes to to diet culture and uh
everything that they've gone through
they they need to uh kind of have a
specific uh regulation of making sure
that they get enough food food and so
it's not that we should be um uh I mean
when we're criticizing the diet culture
what we're criticizing is the fact that
people are limiting what type of
calories they're intaking and we need to
make sure that people are getting the
food that they need they need to be they
need to feel well they need to feel full
they need to feel uh nourished and to
ensure that it's important that I think
that we have this as a resource uh and
that may be separate from the uh the the
other helplines that we have just
because of how prevalent of an issue
this is I mean upwards of 5% of uh of
all people with uh anorexia end up uh
potentially uh in a fatal situation and
uh we need to avoid that at all costs
thank you thank you very much are there
any questions for the
representative thank you all right I'd
like to call
forward Devin
Quinn
my
isor press the uh
I'm Devin Quinn I'm the director of
policy at the New Hampshire women's
Foundation where we invest in equality
and opportunity for the women and girls
of New Hampshire through research
education advocacy and Grant making and
we are very excited to support this bill
um because this will have a very
positive impact on youth but
particularly on girls um girls are more
likely than boys to try to lose weight
and engage in harmful ways to lose
weight but they are also more likely to
ask for help um so if you see on this um
page we have here is that girls uh
report trying to lose weight at greater
rates than boys which is certainly not
the same as disordered eating um but
this is start of this conversation in
this gendered way and if you turn over
the page you'll see that 33% of girls
engage in very harmful ways to try to
lose weight this is self-reported data
from um ybs um and that includes not
eating for 24 hours or more um vomiting
or taking laxatives or taking diet pills
um um we know through claims data also
that um diagnosis of Eating Disorders um
is almost five times as many for girls
than it is for boys both for um
commercial and for Medicaid um enrolled
um children but also um we took a look
at the New Hampshire crisis text line
just as another um opportunity of a
resource for girls um and or or for
Youth and three out of four um youth who
used the crisis taex line were girls so
we know that girls um are definitely
impacted by this issue at a higher rates
and they're also more likely to re reach
out and utilize resources so putting um
a hotline number literally in their
hands is a great way to reach girls all
youth but particularly girls right where
they are so we support this bill and I'm
happy to take any questions thank you
are there questions yes representative
Belcher thank you Mr chair thank you for
that testimony I'd like to look at this
graph for a minute on the back we were
just talking about as far as the the
harmful behaviors that girls have
undertaken in order to lose weight um in
this chart and the biggest chunk of this
is did not eat for 24 hours now um was
this methodology in this specifically
looking for this was done because I want
to lose weight or was there the
possibility that this captured other
things because I'm just I'm just
thinking out loud that I'm Christian
it's not un common for us to fast for a
day Jews commonly fast for a day often
times people fast for a day before going
to get a blood glucose test and they're
required to for their testing people
have to fast for a day before they go
into surgery um there's a lot of reasons
that people might fast for a day it's
been done for a long long time so is
that taken out of this statistic to make
sure this is only unhealthy weight loss
that we're looking at yes so I will
happy happy to follow up follow up with
you on exactly how that question is
worded um in the youth risk behavior
survey um but it um is related to
harmful ways to lose weight okay thank
you further questions from the
committee thank you very much
thanks like to call forward
um Emma
Sai
good afternoon uh chairman lad and
members of the committee thank you for
hearing my testimony today my name is
Emma savini I am the children's
Behavioral Health policy coordinator at
new Futures new Futures is a nonpartisan
nonprofit organization that advocates
for the health and wellness of all
Granite Staters um today I am here in
support of House Bill 1109 um we were
supportive of it last session too um I
will not go into details that have
already been stated so eloquently by the
folks who have already spoken before me
um but I'd just like to underscore the
importance of this bill for youth who
are experiencing Eating Disorders um
those who experience Eating Disorders
are at a higher risk for suicidal
behaviors and so having this helpline
available to them would be um a great
way to um connect those youth with the
resources that can help uh reduce that
risk of
suicidality um again my written
testimony goes over a lot of the same
points that people have made so I'm
happy to take any
questions fine uh thank you very much
are there any questions for new
Futures thank you very much thank
you and I'd like to call Matthew
Brown welcome
Matthew thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee um I said before my name
is Matthew Brown I'm now a sophomore at
marac high school um and I'm very
excited to be back here today in support
of now House Bill
1109 about two years ago now I had an
experience where I was overeating um and
I was feeling uncomfortable and I wanted
to get help so I contacted um a similar
heline to the National Alliance heline
and they were able to give me the help I
needed uh from that experience I
contacted representative rang and we got
the ball rolling and we're here now um I
want to say first of all that every 62
minutes someone will die from an eating
disorder so from the time I've been here
somebody in this country has died from
an eating disorder and uh about 30
million Americans suffer from an eating
disorder this is an issue that is
serious and it's severe and it's
affecting our friends our neighbors and
our family
members I from my own
experience if I I was given only the
option to reach out to the 988 helpline
I would not take that I was not having
suicidal ideations or thought that I was
in a
crisis um I just did it on a whim like
so many children and uh teens do they
feel uncomfortable and they need help
and they reach out um and that
experience definitely helped me and it
has helped thousands of students um I
believe it was representative Damon who
pointed out that uh
almost 300,000 people uh got help from
the National Alliance um and 30% of
those were under the age of 18 um I have
had the pleasure to speak with Joanna
kandell who is the executive director of
that organization um and I definitely
endorse her and endorse her support for
this bill and I'm very pleased to see
that an organization is ready and
willing to Aid the thousands of students
in New Hampshire who are suffering from
an eating disorder Eating Disorders are
mental
illnesses that can be quite different to
ones that we expect they often go
unnoticed and in a climate where um
unhealthy uh body shaming and social
media sort of control a teen's life it's
crucial that health and the information
that is healthy for young people is the
information that's getting out to our
vulnerable populations including teens
and young adults
um now I also want to point out the
severe impact that Eating Disorders can
lead to if not caught early and that is
suicide I believe that any loss of life
should be attempted to rectify by
legislation and I believe that this
legislation does that and it helps to
save lives of the Granite State students
and Granite State young people who are
suffering from eating disorders I know
um it's been a long day and I'm happy to
take any questions if you have any well
thank you for coming back back too so
are there any questions yes
representative Cornell Thank you and I
just want to say thank you for coming
back and and testifying again you did a
great job last year and you're even
better now so thank
you yes represent Woodcock thank you uh
i' like to follow up with exactly what
represent Cornell did was a pleasure to
meet you last year and unfortunately ay
back this year had that little the
little p and hopefully as representative
R introduced this a bill follows the
same path but more successful at the end
I do have a question you said you're a
sophomore this year um and I have no
idea how big merac high school is um you
can probably fill that in for me but
from the from the students you're
associated with and and you know in the
High School uh can you give us a
ballpark idea how many kids might might
um be at this point in time having some
need to use hotline or some need to get
other assistance not not like 20 30 but
10% zero or something just trying to get
an idea what's actually happening in
today's high school yeah um definitely
I'd be happy to answer that question
thank you again representative Woodcock
um so I don't obviously I don't have an
estimation but I would say probably 10
to 20% of teens um and I think there's
data that back that up that um some
teens need support from organizations
like this and unfortunately I don't
believe that there's enough resources um
today I mean if this bill is able to
save life I believe that's that's
crucial thank you thank you you're
welcome are there further questions from
the
committee not seeing hands um good luck
and we really you know thank you for
coming in again with this Bill thank
you and are there any other we that's
the end of the pink cards which we have
up here is there anybody else not hear
seeing any we will close this hearing
and that finishes V business for
today
there take a deep
breath
yeah Oh I thought you were bringing up
more pink cards
gosh put
in technical assistant
okay she's good
girl
okay